huh
jesus christ all right okay i'm getting
really really mad so i yeah
i hope that it's [ __ ] do it i don't
know like when it cut off
it's looking like it's kind of [ __ ]
real jerky right here oh man
please don't tell me that it's it could
be buffering
could just be buffering i'm hulking out
hulking out you're not going to hulk out
i might
you're not going to hulk out your shit's
not even going look at that [ __ ]
yeah it's it's what a students are
buffering
okay why is it buffering oh my [ __ ] it's
like look i got the yellow [ __ ] i got
error youtube is not receiving enough
video to maintain smooth streaming well
um [ __ ] do it youtube come on so uh
what about our connection quality that's
that's
it that's what i just read you okay zach
says looks okay to me
so i don't know well
this is making me it might take a second
it's making me really really annoyed
i'm really annoyed but we'll see
i think jen is watching too much gay
porn on this pc i wish that's what it is
if i was watching gay porn i'd be
watching on this pc because she's
walking
over here [ __ ] like i don't do anything
on this one except stream yeah she's
watching some kind of [ __ ] like
gay gang bangs [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you don't know my life what's that
you don't know my life
i don't know i don't know your life
even if i was watching that i wouldn't
tell you yeah i don't care what you
watch
doesn't bother me you watch what you
want to watch
okay i like gay porn i'm just saying i
had to um
while all this [ __ ] was going on i
grabbed a damn pork shoulder
and he grabbed it i grabbed that damn
park shoulder it was right up the pig
it was fun yeah i put it in water to
kind of speed up the thaw
i'm gonna [ __ ] to put that in the
crock pot tonight make it turn it into
carnitas
for uh so that's what we're gonna have
tomorrow maybe right
we have carnitas for uh tacos
or maybe late i'd like i'll i'm not
really supposed to eat after six or
seven o'clock at night but if i get
drunk enough i'll just be like whatever
it won't be tonight that shit's gotta
cook for like [ __ ] twenty if i can
see
twelve thirteen i had the girl i got
another [ __ ] i can make
if you need something quick we got i got
another [ __ ] i can make it i don't know
i'll think about it so how's the stream
coming we haven't even like got through
this shade
it looks okay it looks a little blurry i
don't know i still got
i i don't know i still got yellow i
still got yellow
is there any way you can refresh that
see what happens
i can't no don't like please don't all
right i don't know
i'm not scaring that constantly scared
yeah because it'll [ __ ] up
even more than [ __ ] up than it already
is some people said they were a lot
youtube is trying to suppress my love
for german expressionism right exactly
because i was like
all i was talking about was cabinet of
dr caligari yeah so see
this is um some more evidence in uh
you know in detriment to your ship it's
like you feel like every time you talk
about whatever you talk about
they're just kind of youtube's turning
out all i was talking about was [ __ ]
kevin of dr caligari
that is not controversial in any respect
it's just
it's random dude okay well we got it
of our audience back okay
let's go ahead and start next on the
list all right so like i said my number
one
my favorite movie from the 1900s to the
19
to 1959 cabinet dr caligari gotta say
okay put one it's the weirdest i think
it was long though
no it's not long a lot of silent movies
were not really
all that long it's like they were like
an hour hour 15 minutes that was like
hard hardship to make
yeah i liked it because like i said i
love
the idea of taking everyone's like i
love the idea of expressionism we're
taking everyone's
final house yeah we're taking everyone's
like
mental states and we're like you know uh
you know we're projecting it outwards
like to the environment and i was really
into so everything like the
the fact that they had to build all
those sets and they looked all [ __ ]
like skewed and [ __ ] i love
i love that so counter to dr caligari
probably my favorite move from that time
period although like i said there's some
competition in that area
all right so like i said that was 1900
1959 so now
we're doing top 20 from every decade
because i could not narrow it down any
further
and even at this point i'm kind of
bummed because i had to leave a lot of
[ __ ] out
okay so we're just saying so now we're
talking about the 1960s
we're going from 20 to one yes
okay number twenty the raven
1963 yeah moral horror comedy
um not really based on i mean boris
karloff was in the ship peter laurie was
in this [ __ ] it was super
fun yeah um like i said i don't know if
i'd call it a horror movie it wasn't
scary it was more of a comedy
i've never seen it as a kid loving it
yeah it wasn't scary at all no it's fun
though
it's super fun and like i said anything
with like [ __ ] peter laureate wizards
and wizard types
all right so we're going with that um
number 19
i don't know if a lot of you guys have
seen this dementia 13.
also from 1963. this is a very very
early film from francis ford coupla
i don't think i didn't see it and it was
kind of like
it's um it's a thriller murder mystery
more than i don't think it has a
supernatural aspect but there's a couple
scenes in it that have like stuck with
me
like since i was a kid since i've seen
it and i actually watched it probably
two years ago and i liked it just as
much it's like
it's really really good like if you
haven't seen it
um number 18 uh probably the first
well is it the first i want to like the
roger corman like edgar allan poe
adaptations because i guess the raven
wants to
but this is another one this is tomb of
lydia from 1964. i
[ __ ] love all of the roger corman
edgar allen poe adaptations they're all
good
yeah um you know tomb of lydia
not my favorite but it's still pretty
[ __ ] good
i i just admire how he could take like a
nothing budget and he probably shot the
[ __ ] in like [ __ ] five days or
whatever
it's like we're making a movie about an
edgar allen poe story and it's like
we're just gonna
and it looked [ __ ] good i mean you
know for the 60s so like i said
team of flag is right up there number 17
i'm gonna go i'm gonna get artsy fartsy
on you
our the wolf 1968 ingmar bergman
[ __ ]
now a lot of people will point to
persona which was also um
that was also a good float too hour of
the wolf
i don't know if i would call it
i don't know what genre i would call it
it's kind of like a horror movie because
it's like creepy as [ __ ]
i found it very creepy like [ __ ] max
vancito was in this when he was very
young
um and it's uh swedish so he's like
speaking swedish in it
and it's basically about he's like an
artist and he's like
he's staying at this place with his wife
and he has all these weird [ __ ]
nightmares
about these people that live
like they go to live on this remote
island and there's all these people that
live on there that are like
and they don't i don't know i'm not like
entirely sure if these people are real
or not
like he has a thing where it's like oh
it's like the dude with the bird head or
it's like all this really weird [ __ ] and
he's like drawing them and saying
it's like super super creepy and there's
like just really creepy
imagery in it you can tell that david
lynch
was super into this movie i mean
if you watch it if you've never seen our
the wolf
watch it and especially if you're into
david lynch because you will be like oh
man that's where he got all
like a lot of his ideas from because
it's like super super creepy
like there's like scenes like oh there's
this woman and like she pulls her face
off and like puts her [ __ ] eyeballs
in the glass and like dudes are like
walking up walls randomly and she'll
like that it's like super super creepy
never seen it yeah it's good though it's
really really good
so i don't know if you guys have seen it
but yeah like check it out badger says
it's great movie it is it's fantastic
abso hour the wolf is probably my
favorite ang mark burgman movie i know a
lot of people as a like persona and
you know i'll get into like mulholland
drive like later on but it's like and i
know that was like
greatly inspired by persona like i said
because david lynch was really into that
[ __ ]
but i don't know for my money our the
wolf is my favorite
just because it's the most like a horror
movie and it's really really really
unsettling so uh number 16 i'm gonna go
with another edgar allen poe adaptation
pitt and pendulum 1961 i love all the
[ __ ]
vincent price [ __ ] i love all that kind
of stuff you know what you forgot though
what i forget
you forgot you forgot the black cat that
was back in the 20s or 30s 30s
that was you know what that was on my
original list but i had to take it off
when i was i like that one too but like
i said this was the problem that i had
because i was trying to winnow it down
to 20
for each thing i'm gonna go ahead and
add one of my favorites thank you
well i was hoping you would and that was
fun because you passed that era
all right [ __ ] the black cat
boris karloff bella lugosi and this
uh boris karloff plays this damn
satanic officer he's from world war one
when it world war one officer
if i remember sure who sacrificed his
own unit
to death at a certain location out on
the battlefield
so he could go back there after the war
and build this [ __ ] castle on that
location
and this [ __ ] it's this high tech for
the day
[ __ ] like art deco damn futuristic
castle spooky as [ __ ]
automatic doors intercoms all kinds of
[ __ ]
but then underneath the bottom he had
underneath the bottom of it
he had like this special storage area
where he had all these beautiful women
preserved inside these glass
caskets well one of his army buddies
shows up looking for him
the bill that goes shows up to try to
[ __ ] challenge him about i know you
lost that battle on purpose
you know turns out he's a big satanist
he's having satanic parties people going
over he's even [ __ ] this is before
the haze code so they could do all kinds
of [ __ ] i want a satanic party
yeah and um
turns out lugosi wants to kill him for
what he did to the unit and he wants to
know where his daughter is
and it turns out and his wife i think
his wife and his daughter and [ __ ]
lugosi killed i think
killed the wife he was sleeping with
lugosi's wife
he said she died but i think he killed
her he had her preserved and then he
started screwing the daughter who is now
like in her [ __ ] teens
and late teens and he she's the
daughter's the new woman
it's [ __ ] bizarre man she's running
around in this elegant kind of
see-through
[ __ ] gown running around she doesn't
know anything about the outside world
lugosi tries to get his revenge on his
old [ __ ] commander
to me for those old 20s type movies it
was an early talkie
that one really stood out because it had
weird ass [ __ ] sexual relations with
[ __ ] women that you stole
from your friends [ __ ] had
human sacrifice in a military [ __ ]
setting
old army buddies meeting back up for
[ __ ] trying to get
vengeance or justice and uh
they're in this [ __ ] futuristic
satanic castle this
art deco type cast they got away with a
lot of [ __ ]
if they if the haze code had never come
down there'd been a lot of badass movies
well a lot of like way more [ __ ] up
horror movies would have happened
earlier than the 1970s uh
yeah and the black cat is not long maybe
not even 90 minutes well like i said a
lot of
older movies about an hour it's like
people piss and moan about little movies
they're so long now like nowadays
they're like back in the old but back in
the old days they were like an hour hour
and 15 minutes
tops yeah what was good about it is that
it was [ __ ] in a weird way it was
kind of sexy
it was kind of a sexy move yeah
ken mentions the aspects which actually
was on my list but i had to take it off
because i had too many
i wrote a big long blog post about the
aspects on my goddess of hellfire post a
couple years back so if you wanted to
check that out because that's a movie a
little like that
a lot of people don't know about it's a
british film um
and it's pretty [ __ ] good i i really
liked it
so you know if you haven't seen it just
might want to go check it out
um all right so where was i so i was
putting the pendulum okay so
uh number 15 the last man on earth 1964
the first adaptation of richard
matheson's
i am legend starring vincent price
probably okay not even probably
definitely the most faithful to the book
because really they haven't made
um a real faithful to the book
adaptation
of i am legend because the omega man
while an awesome movie is not super
faithful this book and i am legend
from with will smith and it was really
not faithful yeah not good
last man on earth because i like i like
will smith i do too like it was an okay
movie until the end
i didn't like the attitude should have
been the omega man with
will smith it would have made a lot more
sense um
the serpent surface said that in in in
the raven he brought this up i just
remembered it
there's also possible necrophilia and i
forgot there
everything had to be like implications
yeah i didn't get that feeling that he's
preserving those women so he could have
sex with him
that was some weird [ __ ] that movie was
that was a lot of weird chicken
was horror way ahead of its time but
what was weird about it is that it still
kind of remained
classy which that was some weird the
weird way that they did that [ __ ] back
then
it kind of had a classy feeling to it
well
there was an art to yeah some weird [ __ ]
i mean you have to admire like the art
behind well we want to put all this kind
of like really scandalous [ __ ] in the
movie but we don't want to say it
outright yeah
and then we gotta kind of work around
the [ __ ] so it's like i really kind of
respect
the [ __ ] that you had to go through back
because nowadays you can just put
whatever in a movie and no one will care
but it's like back in the day you had to
like really work around like all the
laws
i mean you could get into really big
trouble yeah for putting [ __ ] in a movie
um so you had to like everything was
like implication
which in a way kind of made them better
but i don't know like he was tagging the
mother-daughter team of his [ __ ]
yeah from that he stole from his friend
and that was like i remember when i
first saw that you know i was coming out
of the army so i could kind of
deal with this whole army buddy dynamic
and i'm like going
god man that [ __ ] is [ __ ] up
he steals the wife and the daughter from
one of his subordinates and [ __ ]
i guess kills the wife he didn't say he
killed her
he said she died but could you trust
that dude
i don't know i think he killed the wife
to kill the first one
so he could get his hands on the dollar
i mean just what i was thinking at the
time
it was [ __ ] i mean possibly like i
said they left so many possibilities
open
because they had to yeah right around
all of these [ __ ] regulations she
died
and then he was praying out of the satan
out of a satanic bible it was [ __ ]
bizarre
and all these rich people showed up
brian green said vincent price was good
and everything he was
i will watch anything with vincent price
in it i
[ __ ] love vince apprentice yeah and
brian uh [ __ ]
um omega man with heston [ __ ] it did
rock
i love that movie it's not close to the
book but i love that movie anyway i
[ __ ] found out [ __ ] neville you
know [ __ ] neville that's who [ __ ]
charlton heston played
him in his [ __ ] air force colonel
outfit
with the [ __ ] uh with the [ __ ]
smith wesson mk
760 [ __ ] sub machine gun and the hat
in the face
of charlton heston all that [ __ ] is
available and you can make a doll
that looks just like neville i think i'm
gonna make one
yeah with the [ __ ] neville's with
heston's
the [ __ ] hat you can buy it all
separately that [ __ ]
arm uh air force flight suit uh
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] submachine gun
and everything i think i'm gonna make a
neville doll i'll put that [ __ ] right
back over there oh you should
yeah make a neville doll neville this is
why
this is why people piss and moan about
like oh nowadays oh
no there's something really cool no man
it's like
look like the good movies and [ __ ] like
i love all the movies back then
but nowadays like back then it was like
hard like
you know you wanted some memorabilia
yeah from the movies back then you
couldn't
get that you know you can make it yeah
you just make it there's like kits
there's all kind of shoes dude so easy
dudes are 3d printing heston's head you
got to paint it
but fantastic you can get heston's face
and everything i love it now i got to
[ __ ] build that
starship enterprise first she bought it
for me it's got the electronics
with all the [ __ ] lights in the
[ __ ] world
yeah and i just got to get the paint for
it and once this trt kicks in i'll
[ __ ] be
i'll be ready for that [ __ ] paint that
[ __ ] make it look that's kirk's [ __ ]
enterprise
yeah that was the real star trek kirk
all right
oh yeah that's why i got that one they
had other ones but i was like no i need
like the t.o.a yeah i need the [ __ ]
the shot and the moy okay [ __ ] that's
how they [ __ ] played it back then i
love
leonard yeah he's my favorite that was
the best that was the best
series well that's why i got kind of
like inter
it's kind of like twilight zone in space
you know well it's in space
yeah it's on space yeah kind of like
that probably why i like i like both
star trek and twilight zone
and night gallery if you guys haven't
watched night gallery with rutz earlier
and if you like that
if you liked the original star trek and
we did a show on it on youtube for free
you can see star trek continues
and it is it's a lot of the same people
that worked on it yeah it's fan made but
it's really
fan-made oh my goodness it's the final
season
it's the final season to the [ __ ]
to to the old series and it mates up
meets right up to star trek the motion
picture and how it ends it's good well
like i said i admire
anything that's done with love
had had to descend and they got it
scotty's son
plays scotty emmahara [ __ ] plays and
who's
who's dead now he plays sulu [ __ ] uh
yeah he died todd haberkorn plays
[ __ ] spock he does a good job he does
his own version of he's a younger guy
but he's still good
he's good i like his [ __ ] yeah and
[ __ ] the dude who plays kirk well
what [ __ ] he's just in my head
he's [ __ ] a great kirk vic vic vic
mignon
yeah really good um a lot of uh
[ __ ] uh what's his name uh lou
ferrigno shows up plays on an orion
[ __ ] slave master oh
that was a good idea yeah there's a
[ __ ] the the chick from buck rogers
uh
she shows up for some episodes aaron
gray aaron gray shows up
so it's got it's got stars on it and the
writing is
really a lot of times the same guys who
wrote some of the older ones or
guys that wrote for [ __ ] next
generation and [ __ ] it's good
if you're gonna do that it's like do it
out of love
yeah if you do it out of love yeah it
really
it really shows yeah and it's got one of
the best mirror episodes of all star
trek
and that was what did [ __ ] mirror
spot
do once kirk left because look
i mean spock is sexy just in his general
form
but mirrors [ __ ] yeah also sexy
i'm i'm into that um ken says was grant
still in it or did he die before it
ended no
no he was that after he died after they
were done with it because i
which is sadly like [ __ ] he was so young
that burns me out still i don't remember
why he died he died of some sickness
[ __ ] man yeah but if you like the
original star trek man go back and see
star trek continue well because what
they did like every episode
they tried to like um bring
closure to like every episode that was
maybe like open-ended
the original series didn't end sure it
didn't end and they just stopped
all right so they had to make an extra c
an extra season
to wrap all that [ __ ] up kirk had to
[ __ ] come face to face with the fact
that he was a womanizer and he [ __ ]
over all those women
in the whole series they had to come
face face that
[ __ ] it's like you can't just like
sling your dick around like
it's like look the babies come from that
like other spock and nurse chapel had to
be resolved
okay because spock and nurse chapel had
some shadows
and then why did spock why did spock
leave starfleet
because in in in in uh star trek uh
[ __ ] the motion pitcher spot comes
back to join starfleet why'd he leave
all that's in there oh that's in there
so yeah i love that they that they're
like well we're gonna take each episode
that's like iconic
but that was open-ended and we're going
to
resolve it you know what i mean i really
like that they did that
yeah and you could tell that the people
that made it i mean everybody that made
it
they're super super into star trek yeah
which like i said i love that i'm a dork
too it's like i love that kind of [ __ ]
yeah well yeah the the star trek they're
making now discovery i mean
i haven't seen it i'm not judging i've
been hearing like mixed some people say
it's all right
it's not the same star trek they didn't
want to pay all those licensing fees
uh so they kind of got it in a in a
different universe
um most people i'm hearing say it's
[ __ ] it's full of [ __ ]
it's not it's not real star trek um
i don't know i'm not judging i haven't
seen it now the star trek movies
i saw some of them and they were okay
it's not it's a
it's it's it's not the same star trek
it's just isn't
oh it's not my star trek i liked the
next generation
i liked [ __ ] the original series you
like i [ __ ] love star trek enterprise
yeah a lot of people did he's a big fan
of adam i loved enterprise
especially like season with scott two
and beyond what's that
scott it took a while for that one to
start ramping up
these space d space nine was good um
i don't know if i saw any of these guys
i probably did it's
voyager was pretty good i said you know
so okay
i thought it was pretty good oh no maybe
i did yeah it was pretty good okay
uh but my favorite actually is the
original series
the movies that's my favorite the movies
that went with it
and enterprise and a lot of people
looking at enterprise why enterpre
i didn't really like the next generation
that much i mean i liked it but
it took a while for that series to
really get rolling and the thing with
the borg i like that
it's just
they had too much goddamn technology
they jordy could fix anything
that was the problem jo if you had a big
problem
bring jordy's blind ass over here and
he's like well see what we can do is we
can take the
vertical particles and put those in with
the with with the hybrid
and then that's what they call whatever
yeah and that's what they started to get
to be too much with the original series
and enterprise they didn't have
technology to fix [ __ ]
i mean technology did fix [ __ ] every now
and then
but really when you went back to the
enterprise with scott bakula
they were the [ __ ] losers of the
[ __ ] space
of outer space which is more interesting
because if you just have
like the means at your disposal it's
like hey we can just like fix this
problem blah blah blah
then there's there's no drama there's no
conflict
everybody wants to see we have a problem
and we don't know how to solve it that's
drama yeah right so if like if you can
just say hey we can just have our
computer dude
that's really not that interesting some
dude named dog
[ __ ] crap man is trying to come for
you know fiction he's trying he's trying
to be slick doesn't trt cause
erectile dysfunction [ __ ] any kind of
anabolics in high levels can cause it
all right but you have to be way up
outside the [ __ ] window
you have to be what's called in super
physiological levels
if you have super physiological levels
of any hormones that will [ __ ] you up
the key to it is to stay within normal
human levels
of all [ __ ] okay so they know the window
that you go in
and all you're doing is you're restoring
someone's hormonal profile
to an earlier state it's not a
superhuman state it's an earlier state
so that's answering your question yeah
they're just going back to like a
younger
version right and then erectile
dysfunction are you [ __ ] kidding me
i would [ __ ] you on trt then what would
you
have really never had that problem yeah
i'd be like [ __ ] been like that
i mean i'm just saying you have never
had that problem well
get drunk and tired [ __ ] anything
like that
sure but like i have that too i get
drunk or just like dude it's like i'm
not even but it's like yeah
you have seriously never had that
problem not that i know of
anyway and we've been together a long
time ten times
ten years so it's you've never had that
problem
so um where was i
there were fourteen what did i say the
premature burial they did
which had [ __ ] um who's that dude
the dude that was in the mail with the
x-ray eyes i can't remember his name
right now but he was in that [ __ ]
really good um being buried alive
sucks number 13 peeping town
1960. now we did a retrospective on this
so if you want like our full thoughts
about it then go watch the respective
about it
this was a movie it came out the same
year as psycho
which maybe you'll be seeing later on on
the list
but i kind of feel like this movie
was maybe i don't know if i want to say
it was like the first
slasher movie it was the first modern
horror movie
but this is kind of the first one to do
the whole
sympathetic serial killer we're seeing
[ __ ] from his pov
thing you know what i'm saying i don't
know if it was the first one
but it seems like it was kind of among
the first ones
1960 that's very early yeah this is
about a dude who was a photographer
and his whole fetish was
he was into watching women
well he was into fear and he was like
into his like look i i have this camera
and it has like this [ __ ] blade on it
and i'm gonna like [ __ ] stab you to
death while i'm filming you
because i'm into watching you be afraid
that you're dying
you know what i'm saying so very ahead
of its time for 1960.
gotta say it's a british film now the
dude that directed it
very famously he made this movie
and then it was like no thank you and he
essentially like his career kind of
tanked
afterward because evidently the world
was not ready for this [ __ ]
but you know that's kind of what
happened so peeping tom we did a review
on it
like i said go watch that [ __ ] it's in
our movie retro effective
now number 12 i'm gonna go with uh black
sunday
1960. um mario bava
this is has the beautiful beautiful
barber steel
i love old school witchcraft movies
and this movie 1960 italian
it has a scene at the very beginning of
a witch
getting a spiked mask hammered onto her
face
because that's how they did in italy in
1960.
they weren't [ __ ] around it's good i
love witchcraft movies
so black sunday is really really good if
you haven't seen that
you need to see that mario baba
a [ __ ] pioneer in many ways but go
see black sunday and also
you know paul moore's asked me if i saw
oroville they did a better job
they thought he did they did a real good
job on it i keep hearing about oroville
they said if you like old star trek
you'd love orville
yeah i'd be up for that i just haven't
seen it yet
it was a good way of getting around the
star trek enterprise yeah star trek
[ __ ] um
what do you call it uh their licensing
though
you know what i mean yeah somebody
wanted to make like old school star trek
so they did it in kind of like a they
did a
blatant star trek ripoff but then they
added like a comedy
kind of element to it but people liked
that better than the [ __ ]
well like i said yeah there's a lot of
like workarounds you can do yeah they
work around like
properly supposed to be real good mango
says black sunday is great it is great i
love
mario baba i love black sundae i love
barbara steele
i love everything she's in she just
seems like a fantastic i don't know man
she just seems like
a fantastic person she was in david
cronenberg movies too
and i love her and she was like in some
[ __ ] later she was in some [ __ ] that i
saw a couple years ago
there was a movie i saw a couple years
back called what was it called the
butterfly
room i want to say she was in that
and she [ __ ] chewed the scenery and
that [ __ ] and it was
amazing yeah oh my god i love her
but yeah so she's awesome so where are
we okay so pooping time black sunday
number one number 11. yeah i know it's
she's amazing
i love her i love her yeah number 11 i'm
gonna go with
uh the birds 1963.
alfred hitchcock um
probably one of his best films i don't
know there's a lot of competition in
that area psycho's gonna turn up later
spoiler alert but the birds also very
good
and i love the fact that
he went like pretty gory with the birds
back in the day of like 1963
and he showed a body with the eyes
pecked out
yeah i remember that which
1963 i'm like i'm actually amazed that
he got up we was legit
so you know what i'm saying and like the
birds good because it's kind of like
i love that he took something innocuous
and
made it into a threat i think that
is kind of like yeah but you also have
to you also have to talk about the
crowning jewel and that's
burdemic once [ __ ] once
it came out then [ __ ] you know i mean
that totally made the birds obsolete
did it though totally made the birds
obviously i feel like okay
gunshots and the [ __ ] special effects
from burdemic brogenick was like okay
this is what happened like if birdemic
the people that made birdemic and like i
said i'm not
[ __ ] on you person that made
birdemic james dying whatever your name
is
um if you were alfred hitchcock
and you made the burrows back in the day
but also you were
[ __ ] and
had had a lobotomy and did like there
was
many other things and then you decided
you were going to make a movie
then you would kind of make pardemic but
it was
it was entertaining i will i will give
it that much
but you could tell that that was like
the [ __ ] like drug addled version
of the birds it was like look we're
gonna take like all the [ __ ]
we're gonna put like all these [ __ ]
birds from this [ __ ]
um the editing program we're gonna put
like these little png birds in there
like flapping
it's like they obviously like we're not
and then to say oh my god it was just
tina says she's doing some multitasking
oh my goodness
and that's a can if you've seen birdemic
but you've never seen the birds
go see the birds because
it's the same premise um
but a thousand times better executed
i'm just saying but yeah so i'm just
saying
all right so where am i number ten mask
of the red death
1964. this is another one that was the
roger corman
movie uh that he did a whole bunch of
edgar allen poe adaptations most of
which were actually pretty good even
though
roger corman made a lot of um i'm not
gonna lie
like [ __ ] ass movies in the 50s and in
the 60s
but all of his edgar allen poe
adaptations were actually
pretty good you got that right tila
jenny's feeling no pain
she's [ __ ] i'm not it's you know
she's on about drink four probably
yeah is it yeah about a drink four well
i'm just not
i'm not like eight yeah i'm on the third
one
no but they're doubles yeah i think
that's the fourth so this might be the
six okay whatever or seven it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter
we're talking about horror movies i'm
into it
so yeah so roger corman
if you guys don't know if you're too
young he made a lot of uh edgar allen
poe adaptations
in the 60s now prior to this roger
corman had made some movies in the 50s
attack of the crab monsters he'd done
like all these kind of like 50s
now all of his movies made money
because one they were super cheap to
make and two
they appealed to a larger like teenage
audience like a lot of people
go to see them graham said you were
pissed as a cricket yeah
but a lot of them like not so good i've
seen like a lot of the
roger corman movies that run like
[ __ ] teenage caveman and all that
kind of [ __ ]
not great but is ad girl and poe
adaptations
fantastic i love all of those
because i don't know for whatever reason
i don't know if he was like really into
that growing po
or he was just like was willing to like
expend more energy on the [ __ ]
but the edgar allen poe adaptations that
he did
all came out really really good like way
better than any of this other movie city
ever made
because a lot of the [ __ ] that he did in
the 50s even even later in the 70s
were shitty no
well he made some in the 80s that were
good [ __ ] he did i mean they're
entertaining dude he did what was it
they're not
like well actually he did that one with
[ __ ] cameron what was it called
galaxy of terror
galaxy okay that was yeah i see a terror
galaxy of terror that was what
ended up getting corman his [ __ ] gig
on alien 2
on aliens and you know and galaxy of
terror was an alien ripoff
i liked it remember when that big old
[ __ ] caterpillar was raping that girl
everybody remember i was like that's her
she's gonna say suckers not a slime on
her titties it just [ __ ]
that's the only thing i remember [ __ ]
teenager going yeah
damn wish i was that caterpillar
that's funny because of course you well
yeah well roger corman
yeah i will give him this one
he never lost money on a single movie
as far as i know he never did he was
always real big
on i'm going to make whatever and he was
like
really good you guys dollars yeah you
got five dollars
oh thank you dude that was from dude
[ __ ] man get me drunk i will talk about
horror movies all night long
um but yeah so the thing about it is
that
he always kind of was like up on the
zeitgeist man like he always knew what
was going on with the [ __ ]
which nowadays it's like a lot of the
times you see the [ __ ] it's like kind of
dated
but at the time
as i said he never lost money talk about
carmen yeah yeah
he was constantly producing stuff
constantly making things and the fact
that he only took like two or three
weeks to make a movie
which was unpre and he would make a
bunch of movies on the same sets
because he was very budget-minded yeah
well there was an element of scam
in
[Music]
yeah and they were making something that
was entertaining so
you had like a product that came out at
the end that people were entertained but
i can't do that anymore though
so i'm not television basically sucked
in those
in in those days um if you could make a
decent movie and you had connections in
hollywood to get it into theaters on a
nationwide or at least
a regional level you could triple your
money
any investment you could triple it and
if you had the right people you could
sit there and constantly
make these [ __ ] things um and put
your name on them
and [ __ ] buy all kinds of houses and
[ __ ] get all kinds of young
girlfriends
that's really what all they were doing
it wasn't anything
sophisticated well and i feel like roger
corman's formula
is the same thing that bloomhouse jake
yeah that jason blum
blumhouse is doing nowadays it's like
look we're gonna make a movie for five
million dollars
and then it will make a hundred million
dollars
and we will now that i am now that amc
and all those big theater chains are
gone i don't
they're never going to be the size that
they were the future is streaming
[ __ ] it's it's obvious now it's going
to be a slightly different
strategy now i think it might be a
little bit better in some ways because
uh they don't
spend all the money on a bunch of fat
they'll they'll
spend money directly on actors writers
and special effects
well and people that and you know movies
that
people actually want to make
look i don't have a lot of money but
it's like this is something that i've
been wanting to work on sure
if you look at the big hollywood movies
and the budgets involved that's all
[ __ ] it's all padded out with all
kinds of kickbacks uh they're over
claiming how much this [ __ ] cost because
has to do with the irs and their
tax basically tax evasion there's a lot
of [ __ ] going on in the
so-called cost of these big blockbusters
they're not spending that much money and
they're [ __ ] hiring friends that own
companies like special effects companies
and they're over charging and they're
spreading [ __ ] around a lot of
corruption in it
the future productions you're going to
get that same movie it's going to cost a
fraction of that and it's going to
and the production time is going to be
reduced and it's going to be something
you can
buy online that's what it's going to be
and the people that actually worked on
the movie will get the money
not all these other people like i said
i'm just saying i'm okay with that
that's fine i'm okay with that that's
fine look how look how
look at joker okay
you could make joker even cheaper than
they made it all right
and if it was good it would it would
make more than a billion
you know what i mean in the new model
think about it
i think if joker came out now direct
streaming
it would still it would make more than
the billion dollars
than it made at the theater because they
didn't have to pay the theater change to
play it there's all kinds of kickbacks
involved
yeah you understand what i'm saying yeah
okay
um but yeah like i said i'm i'm
really in um i'm kind of on the side of
anything that's going to go toward
more indie movies because i'm kind of
especially in horror i want to see
um you know people's [ __ ] individual
visions man i don't want to see
like all this kind of like committee
[ __ ] it's like some of those are good
but not usually i want to see one
person's [ __ ] vision
man i want to see that you know
i like a director that has a vision they
have like even if it's weird it's like i
love to see
your perspective on [ __ ]
nobody wants to see horror that's
corporate or generic or you know i've
seen something like that and i like them
but it's like
no one remembers that i really like to
see
everyone's individual visions of horror
yeah whether it's movies or whether it's
novels i like either thing
serpent services exactly when i was a
kid i always wondered why a movie cost
200 millions to make but it looks like a
one billion dollar movie
it's exactly the why it didn't cost 200
million they [ __ ] lied
well and the thing about it too is that
when you have
a lot less money to work [ __ ] around
about friends
when you have a lot less money to work
with you have to
um be creative
and i am interested to see how you know
if you're only given a million or half a
million or whatever you're given to make
your movie
i'm always interested to see how you
like spend that and to me
that's more interesting than seeing a
movie that
you know costs like 100 million dollars
or whatever
it's like you know sometimes these are
fun and entertaining or whatever but
it's like i don't
i don't know man i just i i don't like
[ __ ]
resonate with that [ __ ] yeah you know
because
what's the next one on the list
everybody loves that so um
number nine because i said mask of the
red death right yeah i think you did
yeah
number nine blood and black lace i don't
remember that 1964
mario baba this was one of the first
giallo movies it probably wasn't the
first one because i think
um mario baba had made another one
called
uh the man who knew too much which is
black and white
but this was kind of like the first one
that was like that had all of the giallo
um tropes it was full color
it was like set in a model
you know a you know fashion house so
it's like all the models were like
[ __ ] victims
and it was like they had like [ __ ] um
really
uh elaborate like [ __ ] murders it was
all that kind of [ __ ] and it was like a
murder mystery
so i kind of feel like this is really
really um influential
of leadership so if you're into giallo
movies if you're into all that kind of
like murder mystery [ __ ] you really need
to see blood and black ladies 1964
edge 1964. see that [ __ ] [ __ ]
um number eight eyes without a face
1960. this was a french film
now this movie what's the favorite of
billy idol
seriously if you were live in 1960 and
you saw this in 1960
yeah um i can see you getting kind of
like because this is pretty gory for
1960.
like somebody seriously
the story about it is that there's a
doctor and he has a
daughter and he's trying to find her
like her face got all [ __ ] up so he's
trying to like
find her another face um
so there's a scene in it
where the doctor
like cuts off her face in
it's you know it's pretty graphic for
1960
it's like because of her fees and they
pull it off
and they're like putting another one
because you know she has like the
[ __ ] mask on through the whole thing
but
they do the whole thing it's pretty gory
for 1960.
i'm just saying it's a french film
um so if you haven't seen it it's uh it
was directed by
uh georges trent franju
and i feel like a lot of people maybe
haven't seen this one but
i don't know it's like it's this is
another one that if you're
super into horror you really need to see
this one because [ __ ]
you know i spot a face man it's like
you'll be surprised
at how people
reportedly passed out when they first
showed this
because there was a scene in it where
the doctor
is like cutting the face off and like he
pulls the face
off of the and it's like shown
so he pulls the face off and [ __ ] like
that which i feel like in the us
they wouldn't have shown in 1960
i i feel like they wouldn't have shown
that right
no probably not so i kind of feel like
i don't know a lot of people were like
upset by it but i don't know but
you know seriously see that one eyes out
of base
1960. number
seven where am i at carnival of souls
62. i
love incredible souls
this is the weirdest [ __ ] movie this
woman that was in it
what did she do afterward i don't really
know her name is candice hilagos
so this movie was so [ __ ] weird
so she spoiler alert
um dies in a car accident
essentially well she's in a car accident
at the beginning
and then like the whole movie like you
think that she survives the car accident
so the whole movie she's kind of like
[ __ ] around and like all this kind of
[ __ ] like the whole premise of the movie
is that
she died in the car accident but like
her soul
is not is like floating around out there
or whatever
and so it's it's a it's a thing where
it's like it's kind of like
i don't know she doesn't have a soul now
so she's walking around but she doesn't
have a soul
so that's kind of the whole premise of
the movie
she dies in the car accident but she
doesn't realize it
and then like she's walking around like
she's doing [ __ ] like oh i'm playing the
church oregon it's like oh i can't deal
with it anymore like i keep playing like
demonic [ __ ]
and then like she goes to this other
place and it's like i don't know it's
i don't know there's something really
weird about it and it's like there's
this [ __ ]
um what do you call like the [ __ ]
carnival over there and there's like all
these [ __ ]
dudes that are like look like zombies
and then like all white with like the
black eyes and they're
showing up in her car window while she's
driving around it's like i don't know
like
i love this move there's something like
really really creepy about this movie
did you find that or not no not really
[Laughter]
he really does not no i didn't really i
didn't really care for the movie
no souls right i love carnival souls
yeah
there's something really like creepy
about it i thought which one was this
again
you don't even know no i imagine i think
it's a woman that
at the very beginning she's in a car
with a bunch of our friends and they
have a drag race
and they go off the bridge
they go off a bridge and then over the
course of the movie she
it seems like she survives the accident
i've never seen it
but some weird [ __ ] happens where
she starts like having these weird like
um episodes where it's like
oh i can't hear anything i still like it
but and she has this thing where it's
like she can't
she used to be a like a church organist
she can't do that anymore
i've never seen it you've never carnival
of souls jenny i've never seen it
oh my god okay never mind it's not a
carnival of souls
it's good watch it all right um
it's creepy so number six
night of the living dead yeah 1968.
yeah [ __ ] george romero
yeah goodbye the godfather everybody
knows this one
of zombie films yeah pretty much because
all the zombie films before this
and there weren't very many of them all
the zombie films before this were
you know haitian unit style
zombie movies it was kind of like this
whole hey we're bringing you back from
the dead
to be a slave or whatever that was like
the whole zombie thing
george romero established the whole he
kind of put together the whole
zombie mythos with the whole ghoul
mythos as in someone that
had come back from the grave and was
eating other people's flesh
so he kind of like combined those two
uh you know legends
and made kind of a whole new thing
essentially yeah
i don't i'm not really aware of anyone
that had done that
before him yeah but
night of the living dead is
i mean this isn't it its influence can't
be understated
i don't think it
essentially this movie established the
entire zombie
sub genre yeah even though it wasn't
about zombies
they called them zombies they didn't
call them zombies in the movie they were
just called the walking dead or the
living dead
and the zombies yeah
zombies weren't the walking dead really
zombies were re-animated people it's a
haitian thing
best thing about best thing really
the best thing about this movie is the
[ __ ] cast
the cast and the tone of this movie and
the fact that it was
very organic it was something that was
just kind of made up
i want us i don't want to say on the
spot it was just made up
with what they had a local yeah sure and
they put the best actors in the proper
roles and the [ __ ] just felt very
organic
this was i remember this berg movie yeah
i remember seeing it
in california on television when i was a
little kid
probably some midnight movies midnight
playing on the local [ __ ] channel 13
or something
and i was just [ __ ] blown away by it
i think i actually woke got up and woke
up early out of bed
and then walked into the living room and
watched it all my parents were still
asleep i think i was about
six all right because
i think this might have been like a two
o'clock movie or something
you know i probably think i was supposed
to be up and it [ __ ] blew my mind man
i [ __ ] loved it
this kind of scared me you know at about
six seven
well what was funny is that it wasn't
that gory
even though when they showed the face of
the person at the top of the stairs
it really didn't impact although 1968
seeing someone eating another person it
was mind-blowing
right eating a bug or eating other
people's intestines
was pretty out there for 19. i remember
watching and not knowing exactly what
was going on
who they were hire who they were hiding
for and then when you heard on their
[ __ ] television
the television they had there that the
dead were coming back to life was the
television or radio
it might have been the radio huh no they
had both they had the tv and the radio
and
all the television said that the dead
were coming back to life and they were
eating the living
and as a kid i was like what that was a
concept i had never thought of
[ __ ] now yeah i was like no way
yeah it was a good movie and then he got
killed at the end and everything i was
like [ __ ]
i mean you have to think of the cultural
impact
yeah even people that haven't seen noted
living dead
from 1968 you still know
of the repercussions
of that movie that movie was like
in in hindsight was like an atomic bomb
in the horror genre seriously
because like i said before that all the
quote-unquote zombie movies were
haitian zombies it was it was very like
um
it was very insular it was like a small
kind of um subsect of like the horror
genre somebody in the name of travel guy
videos and tour guides is six watching a
horror movie
oh you know oh i don't know where you're
coming from but what country what
country were you brought up in
we watched horror movies as little kids
i started watching horror movies when i
was maybe
six or seven yeah my parents were pretty
cool about it like
seven and eight i was going in l.a when
i was little
like i was super into scary [ __ ] so it
was like my parents were like okay cool
like you're cool right you know it's not
real i'm like yeah no that's not real so
they would let me watch it
at seven or eight i was going to the
[ __ ] flood control systems in l.a and
going down to the tunnels looking for
the giant ants out of them
which i moved there was a movie called
them and it was from the 50s
i think i i think giant ants lived in
the damn flood control system so we were
going in there looking for
them [ __ ] torches and [ __ ] we stayed
out all day we only had to come back
until the street lights turned on
come on come back all the street lights
come on okay
so we were we were out all day yeah run
around like a pack of wild dogs with
wild dogs we had we little boys and wild
dogs ran together
back in those days well not a lot yeah
they didn't give us it wasn't any of
this [ __ ]
you keep your kids at home under
[ __ ] some kind of locking key because
it's safe
we didn't have that concept back then we
were like real humans
spent all day [ __ ] around stealing
gasoline from the garage
or our parents [ __ ] [ __ ] on fire and
stuff
no they cared it wasn't they didn't you
know
they cared it's just that that was
normal
think about it no i know that wasn't
until i'm making a joke
yeah well other people from other
generations may not understand that
it wasn't until like the 80s of the 90s
people got scared to let their kids
outside
that's why we have generations and
generations of cowards
cowards of weakness and weaklings
[ __ ]
we grew up outside like wild animals
then that's the way you should grow up
that's why all the kids in the third
world grow up
the united states was kind of like a
third world country back then which was
in a way a good thing because i moved to
brazil
and it was very normal in brazil very
you know
and it was developing but it was [ __ ]
i fit right in
all right where was i not eliminated
okay nice 68. so number five
psycho 1968. we
just did a review of psycho one two
three and four
a couple weeks back so go look that up
psycho
again along with peeping tom was kind of
like
the template for
horror going forward in the sense that
you were given an insight
into the psychology of the
bad guy the villain so i feel like this
and peeping tom were kind of like the
first movies that gave you
um an insight into
the serial killer which was something
that
really wasn't done in movies i feel like
when
particularly the haze code because i
feel like
the haze code was kind of like like if
someone's a bad guy
um they have to be punished at the end
and that was not necessarily
what happened in
peepingtown or psycho not to the same
extent that you would expect
so i kind of feel like psycho peeping
tom
kind of like heralded a new era in
horror where
um the morality is like very ambiguous
it's very like gray you know what i'm
saying it's not just kind of like we're
having good guys and bad guys
we're gonna give you like a little bit
of sympathy for the killer we're gonna
like do this and that the other
and i kind of feel like that hadn't
really been done up to that point
so like i said psycho was the one that
was like super famous we talked to this
uh about this on our psycho review and
also
on our peepingtown review peeping tom
which was uh was a british film
and the director michael powell kind of
his uh
career got kind of ruined a little bit
because of this particular movie because
it was so controversial
but i kind of you know psycho was a lot
more successful but
the thing about it was that no one was
really used to
seeing a essentially serial killer
portrayed as a villain but also
sympathetically people were not really
ready for that
in 1960 i kind of feel like
but that's what both these movies did so
like i said psycho's my 1960 night uh
is my number five number four
the innocence oh that was a good movie i
like 1961.
based on henry james classic short story
turn of screw which has been made into
[ __ ] tons of movies but i have to say
this 1961 version
kind of hard to stop this one kind of
hard to stop it
yeah the thing about the turn of the
screw
the thing about the innocence creepy
well the thing about it is that and i
feel like i'm going to talk about this
later because
some of the [ __ ] that's later on the
list
are there ghosts or are there not ghosts
that's what it's all about it's
scarier when you don't no yeah
i always thought that there were ghosts
i thought there were the ghosts which
like i said
she convinced me we watched another
verse says no the ghosts weren't there
and i was like i don't know man but you
could read it either way and that's why
it's all because we're there that's why
it's awesome
yeah good movie i mean the innocence
i mean for my money that is easily
easily i don't even say there's no
competition in this area the innocence
from 1960
that is the best version of the turn of
the screw
that has ever been put to film ever
so it's so good it's just so good
and i love the fact i love ambiguity you
guys know
yeah but i don't know man it's
it's the better the best adaptation okay
and we
like we saw the turning yeah it wasn't
as good
but okay it was good until the end yeah
we're starting to get into the more
modern movies i think that people i
haven't gotten
we're starting to get into the more
modern movies i think people will will
appreciate
the list now a little bit better because
those old ones were old
i don't i didn't see half of those okay
well
that's on you isn't it okay well i
haven't got to the 60s yet
i'm not to the end of the 60s yeah but
we know these the innocence
19 that's number four yeah number three
number three
rosemary's baby that's good flick oh my
god
and like look if you guys haven't read
the book it's by ireland
don't read all that [ __ ] because it's
not all good but he wrote the stepford
wives also
um he also wrote a kiss before dying
awesome book
uh read that uh rosemary's baby a
fantastic
fantastic adaptation because there's so
much [ __ ] going on in that
yeah um also a lot of like there's a lot
of comedy going on in that but i feel
like
it's not acknowledged
which i kind of love that yeah if you're
a catholic it's funnier
i guess con if you haven't seen
apocalypse now man you gotta see that
yeah see the redux version it's real
good it's long but it's
real good you'll understand it yeah okay
um
number two is repulsion repulsion yeah
right you're starting to need helps here
soon you're no i'm not
okay all right well i i don't know if
you're going to stop this i'm not
drunk you're kind of drunk number two
repulsion yeah um
this was the first of roman polanski's
quote-unquote apartment trilogy yeah
catherine de nov was in this it was
black and white
and it was basically about this woman
she was in her apartment she lived with
her sister
and she had like a weird fear of men it
wasn't weird because
like it was justified to a certain
accident
but she lives in this apartment she gets
left alone like her sister goes off on
whatever and like she's in this
apartment by herself and she slowly goes
insane and
it is a fa like roman polanski as shitty
as he is a human
i get that but he's really good at
portraying
dissents into madness he was a good
director man
i mean the tenet was awesome well that
will come up later
yeah um but yeah so it's like so this
movie this was the first like i said of
his apartment trilogy which
it's not really a trilogy they don't
have anything to do with each other they
were just
like all set in apartments but the thing
about it is that
it's just it's this great portrayal of
descent into madness he was like really
really good
at just capturing that on film
yeah streaming a long time i don't know
okay well listen
an hour an hour but i don't remember how
we got to keep it we got to keep it
going forward
all right number one is the haunting oh
my god it's a good one
the haunting 1963. you guys
this is the best adaptation i know like
mike flanagan did the haunting of hill
house which was
loosely an adaptation of the haunting of
hill house by shirley jackson which
i don't know if you guys know is my
favorite haunted house novel
of the 20th century but
the haunting from 1963
is my favorite horror movie of the 1960s
easily
there was no argument there was no
nothing
like i immediately put that the thing
that is awesome about the haunting it
was directed by robert wise
is that he shows nothing
he shows nothing and it is still
scary okay it's all
suggestion it's all angle is all shadow
it's all this
it's all it's amazing the way he [ __ ]
does it well the novel is kind of like
that too
because the novel is
a little bit like is the house
haunted or is eleanor the main character
is she um does she have mental problems
that is making
it is it manifesting in the house um you
know
is she seeing all of it is it so it's
like this ambiguity now love it
like the [ __ ] novel which came out in
1959
is amazing and if you haven't read it
you really should
but this adaptation of i think like
captured the best [ __ ] about shirley
jackson's
writing okay so that was number one for
the 60s yes
okay now we're going on to 1970s number
20
martin 1978 yes
yeah all right um martin was about the
uh
the the rats wasn't it no what was which
one was martin
that was uh george romero yeah and it
was a
um notably like uh this is a vampire
movie
oh yeah yeah yeah martin that was the
guy who thought he was a vampire maybe
he was a vampire
maybe he was maybe he wasn't okay yeah
that was a pretty good one
they left that kind of open-ended now 19
deep red that was 1975.
yeah i don't know that one also known as
profondo rosso
okay um kind of age yellow movie um
one of my favorite jealous yeah from the
70s
uh you know so you're rushing me along
well no i have to keep it moving because
we have so many of them to do we can't
have a three-hour show
and people are saying that if you have
one more drink he won't be be speaking
english
that's something that's not well now we
just have to keep it moving
each each movie each movie we're going
to talk is a brief
brief description of that movie we can't
do a whole show based on each movie
yeah yeah david june says dang tom
trying to get the song
the show over man it's 19 we're still in
1970 we got so much [ __ ] man we got
19. deep red otherwise known as
performance like i said
dario argento check that [ __ ] out um
number 18 the brood yeah yeah yeah david
crenberg
yeah it was a great movie and like any
david cronenberg movie i'm so into that
that was like uh 1979.
reid was in that [ __ ] if you guys
haven't seen the brood it's a good one
it's about [ __ ] uh
messed up yeah what was the dude his
name british dude who's always [ __ ]
oliver
i just said that i'm drunk yeah oliver
reed has this [ __ ] clinic where he
does
hypnosis on people so their version of
reality comes
true and somehow he makes a woman who
can give birth
spontaneously to all these little
children like an ant queen
and they go out and she flicks the fetus
yeah and they literally
they can lift here they can hear her
subconscious and they do her bidding
it's [ __ ] weird
it's a really good movie i know
the brood is honestly one of my
favorites creepy saw it as a kid yeah
it's creepy
number seven number 17 [ __ ] good
movie the original phantom yeah the old
one
1979. i love this movie don cascarelli
directed it
i love this movie because it is so
[ __ ] like i'm a writer
this movie is so [ __ ] weird like the
whole premise of it
is [ __ ] weird and i love that he just
like leaned into it he's like whatever
man
i'm just gonna like gonna make this
movie and i'm just gonna like [ __ ]
look there's a [ __ ] cemetery and
there's this dude and there's like these
[ __ ] jawas and like
they're another dimension or whatever
and it's just like
i love that [ __ ] just lean into the
weird [ __ ]
yeah just saying fantastic let me run
the show let me run the show
travel guide i know what i'm doing you
gonna run it no well just because we
finished this doesn't mean the show ends
okay well we have a couple of we've got
other [ __ ] we gotta do let me let us
know we're only in the 1970s this was
like i said
you're in the audience you're not up
here on this doing the show okay uh
19 uh number 16 carrie
1970 thanks ken appreciate it thank you
ken
number 16 carrie gary that's a [ __ ]
good one
one of the best stephen king adaptations
yeah stephen king wrote about me and
that the man one of the main characters
tom ross
it was remember that [ __ ] it was it was
[ __ ] psychic
uh sissy's basic was cute as [ __ ] then i
mean
she was like the perfect person to play
that character
i mean they went a little bit afield
yeah
well like uh like they always do like
[ __ ] psychokinesis
the thing about like i feel like [ __ ]
spacek was the perfect person to play
that role because she is the perfect
um you know kind of like balance between
being like cute as [ __ ] and also being
kind of like
awkward and i feel like that was kind of
like the best
way to approach that because she's still
like sympathetic but she's also kind of
like a little bit
you know yeah so there's that uh
number 15 and some people are gonna like
yell at me because this is so low
number 15 halloween 1978.
i love halloween i'm not saying that
there were like so many movies like the
1970s
i had 60 movies and i had to cut out
40 movies yeah and when i was putting
them in order
i was having a really hard time what was
funny
is about phantasm and halloween
were movies that were made up out of
nothing really and there wasn't any
money there
they just kind of one of them [ __ ]
phantasm was a [ __ ]
was a move it was a work of [ __ ] love
really and that began a whole [ __ ]
series of movies that were all works of
love
i mean they didn't start the slasher
genre because that hadn't been done
prior black christmas
you know mario babies bay of blood or
whatever yeah but it's like they
brought it into the mainstream yeah and
halloween was carpenter flick back when
he was [ __ ] poor
and still hungry so he uh it's obviously
interesting in making a movie
movie it's a great movie it's great i'm
a big fan of carpenter but especially
early carpenter
as soon as the thing
bombed at the [ __ ] theater uh at the
box office
that was kind of the end of carpenter
physically or psychologically i think
because he was just crushed by the fact
that he made a [ __ ] awesome movie
which bumped me out
and yeah seriously wait till we get
people didn't like it but i [ __ ]
loved it my dad took me to see it like
three times
and i love halloween like i understand
it's
cultural significance right but
what i try to do when i was making this
list i'm like look
if somebody told me hey you want to
watch this movie right now
um i was kind of like judging it as like
how often do i want to like re-watch the
[ __ ] yeah
i love halloween but
it's not there's a lot of other movies i
would rather
watch other than that see um season of
the witch
or halloween three was the first
halloween movie that i saw so i didn't
know anything about one or two
i [ __ ] love season of the week i love
halloween i like that better than the
michael myers movies because
that's what i saw first and that was
just a weird
[ __ ] movie man with the robots and
the you know
two more days to halloween halloween
it's just creepy the kids heads
roaches roaches and snakes come out of
the kid's head and attack the parents
which i love that
any movie that's like willing to like
[ __ ] up a kid like that yeah
that's my respect i was [ __ ] blown
away
[Laughter]
okay all right so after halloween number
14
the omen yeah the almond 1976. this was
a big budget [ __ ] love them yeah the
omen with almond one was i love that
big budget [ __ ] it had a [ __ ]
classic [ __ ] gregory peck was it
it was classy as [ __ ] and you were
buying into it like this david warner
was in this
it was like this [ __ ] was a documentary
it's like
yeah okay can i say the antichrist time
if for the antichrist has arrived and
next thing you know
i'm gonna have we're gonna talk about
that show later i'm gonna have old
fat man showing up about any wine before
it's time about boogenhagen
what's this motherfucker's name [ __ ]
yeah or something orson welles shows up
and tells me
third antichrist and all that kind of
[ __ ] oh we're gonna get into that later
if we have time
we will if we have time and just i'm
just buying into it when i was a kid i
was going that's right
omen [ __ ] can i say like when i saw
the omen
when i was little kid because this came
out 1976 i was four
so i probably saw it when i was
eight nine something like that yeah so
the
the whole scene where david warner gets
decapitated by the paint of glass
that traumatized me for many many years
yeah
yeah khan halloween three scared me too
when i was a kid man
there's some great [ __ ] scenes in
there like the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] with
the
there was something illicit about it it
looked cheap and dangerous like some
kind of [ __ ] snowflake when it came
out
that girl's playing around with that
silver shamrock label
and it [ __ ] blows into her mouth and
[ __ ] her teeth up and a potato bug
comes out
that's just some weird [ __ ] man weird
[ __ ]
yeah good movie it wasn't not was it a
good movie
yeah it was a good flick
i guess we're going to talk about that
later we're going to talk about the
later we're talking about the omen right
now
all right omen almost classy i love that
number thirteen number thirteen jaws
jaws yes
i mean you can't like [ __ ] argue jaws
is a great movie not just a horror movie
not just a it's just a great movie jaws
was the original all-around joke it was
the original blockbuster it was also the
original terminator
that too because arnold schwarzenegger
and the terminator really that rolls a
lot like
there was no concept i didn't talk about
it it couldn't talk to it
there was no concept of blockbuster
summer movies
until jaws that was kind of like the
first
one and honestly i grew up in florida
i grew up in daytona beach which is if
you don't know is
right on the coast so we had like shark
[ __ ] to deal with all the time and i was
always scared of sharks
after i saw jaws i'm just like yeah i
think i'm just like not gonna go
in the ocean i hear all i see all the
[ __ ] comments any time
taylor jones is a masterpiece i mean
the best part of it was the damn sea
captain his eyes like a dog
classy eyes i mean he's the best
character but
all the characters are good and like the
thing about it
and like a lot of people talked about
this so we don't like [ __ ]
like belabor the point but the fact that
the [ __ ] animatronic shark that they
had for the show which was called
bruce and it didn't work the way they
wanted it to
so they couldn't show it as much in the
movie but
that ended up being a positive in the
movie because
as i've said many times in horror
you can't show too much of the [ __ ]
or it's not scary yeah if you're gonna
like have some [ __ ] with a [ __ ]
great white shark don't show it too much
sass is in there painting we're talking
to why she's pain
khan and [ __ ] says they need to do
the storyline halloween three again
they need to reboot season of the witch
they call that [ __ ] silver shamrock
and they [ __ ] have all and they do
watch the whole series
they got dudes got androids the [ __ ]
explosive masks
he's doing all kinds of [ __ ] online kind
of like an updated version
but it has to be [ __ ] tacky it has to
be [ __ ]
you see it you go ugh it's got to be
something like that well it's tacky but
i don't know they have to like kind of
just get that [ __ ] line of
yeah i don't know number two i'm not
sure this is a [ __ ] horror movie
there's gonna be 12. just number 12.
number 12 eraser
now i am going to i did not realize that
was most of
david lynch's movies i would argue
are horror movies yeah and hopefully you
guys are not going to listen
to [ __ ] [ __ ] on me because when i get
to 2000's
spoiler alert there's going to be some
dave lynch showing up in there
eraserhead is absolutely horror movie
absolutely yeah and
i mean david lynch to me
he is the only director
that has been consistently able to
capture what looks like an
like one of my nightmares on film
serpent surfer [ __ ] come out with a
good [ __ ] quote your hand's been
counting money all your life
yeah he knows the deal
but like i said i'll argue because some
people will be like oh david lynch
movies aren't horror movies [ __ ] that
i he is the only director and i wish
that more horror directors would take
some [ __ ] pointers from david lynch
because david lynch
he's not even trying to make a horror
movie he's trying to make like a movie
you know like he wants to make a movie
but
the fact that he he is able to capture
imagery in his [ __ ]
that has creeped me out more than any
other horror movie
like look at some [ __ ] from like [ __ ]
mulan driver like
inland empire like [ __ ] like that has
creeped me out more than any other
horror movie ever
yeah because you know so i'm gonna say
eraserhead
is totally horror maybe okay and
wikipedia will agree with me
all right so same year 1977 number 11
this is the psychic also known this was
directed by lucio folchi
yeah also known as uh murders to the
tune of seven black notes
this is kind of a jealous movie but
not really because there's a
supernatural element
for some reason i don't know why more
people don't know about this movie
i [ __ ] love the psychic because
there's a thing where it's kind of like
i don't know it's
it's like this really weird thing like
the dude that wrote it dardana sachate
he's the same dude that did like the
beyond the house by the cemetery and all
that
like [ __ ] that you guys know about but
he also did this [ __ ] where
it has this thing where there's this
woman that's in it and she's a psychic
and she has like a
vision at the beginning and she sees all
of this stuff
and all of the stuff that she sees comes
to pass
later in the movie but not the way you
expect and i think that's like really
really really
good writing so i i don't know
like i'm really into that premise where
it's kind of like hey
i'm seeing this vision and it's like i
see all these like
[ __ ] because she sees all these like
disturbing imagery
and then like later all of this stuff
happens in real life but
not in the way that you're expecting
that they would happen so i think that's
like
really really good writing and
this is a movie it's kind of like
there's a supernatural element but it's
mostly like a murder mystery
um and i feel like lucio fulchi didn't
get enough credit for
his murder mystery type [ __ ] so every
time
i can plug one of his giallo's or his
murder mysteries
i'm gonna do it so if you haven't seen
the psychic
aka seven to the seven you know
merged the two seven blackness whatever
the [ __ ] you called it in italian
um you should see it because it's really
really good it's actually one of my
favorite lucio holds your mouth okay
number 10 alice sweetheart sweetheart
19.
1976 it's a good flick we have actually
done a
um a retrospective on this yeah this was
awesome it feels like a dialogue but
it's it was influenced by a gentleman
yeah it's an american
fake jollo from [ __ ] 76 and as a kid
i always thought it was a giallo
it looked like some of the [ __ ] was
[ __ ] dubbed but i guess it wasn't
but it looked like now they used to dub
certain languages it just has that
italian feel
about a crazy little [ __ ] girl and a
[ __ ]
perverted mother fat [ __ ] that's
trying to get him some off this like 13
or 14 year old
and then there's like a murderer
involved and [ __ ] and she and i guess
she's going around killing people
but it's a jala movie there's always a
twist it's a good [ __ ] flick
that's kind of what jealous do they're
just kind of like it's
honestly it's the least yeah you know
essential person number nine texas
chainsaw massacre
1974 of course i mean
a classic i and i feel kind of bad like
putting this this
low but there were so many other movies
that i loved from the 70s and it's like
i don't know
it just made me feel better i mean texas
chainsaw massacre everybody knows this
one though
everybody's everybody knows everybody's
got to see them it was i tell you what
oh [ __ ] i ain't going to talk about what
never mind what are you going to say
no well it was back in high school you
know what happened
you know i told you what happened
[ __ ] i was watching the whole [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah i was in high school
[ __ ] with this [ __ ] hot chick
named cheryl
[ __ ] must been about 11. she gave me
a [ __ ] blowing me dear
[ __ ] texas chainsaw mascara that was
a keeper
yeah she was [ __ ] had the nice build
like this and everything she was built a
lot like
redhead though crazy ass red i'm a
redhead too she was cool that's right
yeah
okay number eight the other 19th century
classic we have also done a
retrospective on this
now you guys if you have not read the
novel
by thomas trion you should probably read
the novel
which is excellent thomas tryon wrote a
really good he wrote the other he wrote
a harvest home
which is fantastic if you haven't read
that
so they made a movie the other 1972.
it's kind of like this whole evil twin
thing i'm not going to spoil it like we
did a [ __ ]
retrospective on it i want to spoil it
no i can't spoil it it's about a [ __ ]
uh two twins that are [ __ ] have a
psychic
link everyone's bad one is good it's
back in the early 1900s
yeah and there's a [ __ ] kind of like
a spiritual
guy and their grandma's a spiritualist
slash kind of like
hagen pleaser yeah it's a [ __ ]
masterpiece like we grew up with it as
kids
and it scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of us
me too
all right number seven this is a great
movie
great [ __ ] movie the movie the legend
of zelda
house 1973 some of the hottest [ __ ]
british chicks you could have [ __ ]
imagined based on a novel by richard
matheson
which is just which is just called house
it's all kinds of [ __ ]
lesbianism pamela franklin demon demon
possession
with the girl i think you know what
please correct me if i'm wrong but i
feel like
pamela franklin who was you know older
in this movie
she was um she was in a lot of [ __ ] as a
kid
do i i want to say she might have been
in the innocence
ken's [ __ ] doesn't doesn't two twins
mean four okay
it was a parent these two kids are twins
yeah
two boys they're twins and [ __ ] it's
some it's a weird [ __ ] there's like a
psychic link between them
i'm not going back on that we passed
that movie already
are we talking about legend of hellhole
we're talking about legend of hell
legend of hell house
rodney mcdowell was in it um
i love yeah it's a classic haunted house
movies
it's done kind of like in a hammer
horror style but a little more
it has like a of scientific angle
you have that parapsychology yeah yeah
parapsychology real good flick
number six burnt offerings
this was another [ __ ] badass flick
haunted house
possession you got [ __ ] oliver reeve
in it you got
sexy ass karen black jackson that's sexy
i always say sexy ass karen black
because karen black sex got a sexy ass
[ __ ] caught her sexy cross-eyed ass
she was in it with some kids and the
[ __ ]
the the house is a [ __ ] haunted house
trying to possess
people can i just say to you that you
should
if you like burnt offerings the movie
you should read the book
by robert marasco which is also
fantastic
i read a long time ago but the book
the movie so so good i mean karen black
oliver reed
it's like it's so so good and so creepy
with like the [ __ ]
this is one of the movies i was at a um
what do you call it like a [ __ ]
slumber party
yeah and we watched this movie and
everybody like
ran and hid under the couches okay
all right here's another one [ __ ]
number five we're getting
tenants the the tenant 1970s
this is roman poland this movie very
much disturbed me as a kid
second movie in the apartment trilogy
they were planted on [ __ ] cinemax and
hbo back in the early 80s like around 81
82 a lot
uh at night like on fridays and
saturdays [ __ ] because when you were
a kid
you weren't old enough to go out and
party with the [ __ ] people that were
in their [ __ ] 20s
or the late teenagers so you're just
like trapped
at home watching [ __ ] hbo watching
these scary ass movies
hoping the skin flake could show up but
they never really did like where are the
titties
yeah they're like we see some but not
really and then
the tenant would come on and it was just
a very alienated
terrible movie terrifying movement
moves into this step apartment and it
slowly possesses him and takes over his
mind and you don't know what's real
what's not real it's a [ __ ]
i mean it's a good one like one
like seriously two of my favorite film
scenes of all time
are him because roman polanski plays
the dude like in the movie he's in the
[ __ ] too
yeah and like he moves the [ __ ] aside
and like he's like oh there's a hole in
the wall i'm gonna put and there's a
[ __ ]
tooth in there like oh it freaks me out
and then it's like he doesn't have a
bathroom like it is an apartment
so like the bathroom is like across the
[ __ ] you know
hall or whatever and he looks out the
window
and he goes in the bathroom and there's
like [ __ ] hieroglyphics
yeah like all over the [ __ ] oh it
says he's starting to suffer from
paranoia like all the people are coming
in
okay number four don't look now 1973. i
don't know this one
nicholas roig now this was you saw it
because we did a review
you did okay donald sutherland is in
this this is the dude he goes to
um work on some [ __ ] in uh italy
he's british his daughter has drowned
and uh it's based on a uh
[ __ ] man uh i can't remember right now
i'm too drunk
okay but so he goes to italy and he's
like
um you know working on the [ __ ] it's
like a [ __ ]
uh what do you call a cathedral and he's
working on restoring it
and what ends up happening is that his
daughter is drowned back in england and
he goes to italy to forget about it
and then this whole [ __ ] happens where
[Music]
um his wife starts getting convinced
that there is another there's this woman
in
italy that is a psychic and is like hey
i'm talking to your daughter
i'm doing this so this all kind of [ __ ]
like weird [ __ ] happens where he's like
in italy like all
and he starts seeing what he thinks is
his daughter
around the city okay except it turns out
that it's a serial killer okay because
there's
all that [ __ ] going on too um this
is this is easily one of my favorite
movies
70s it's like so i don't know and
i don't even know why it's like it's so
so [ __ ] creepy
okay there's just all this like [ __ ]
creepy [ __ ] going on
i love all of this kind of [ __ ] where
everything is like ambiguous it's like
like we don't know if it's like it's a
haunting or if it's like serial killers
it's just like
just creepy [ __ ] going on i love that
kind of show okay
number three 1979 alien alien this is a
[ __ ] great
i mean sci-fi horror really nothing
needs to be said about this
this is this was a [ __ ] classic
ridley scott
they paid attention to every detail um
[ __ ] great acting just great special
effects
this i saw this in the theater my dad
took me to see it twice
i would have been 10 years old at this
time
and [ __ ] i loved it scared the [ __ ]
out of me
game changer game changer movies were
not the same
after alien it was at least not sci-fi
yeah it was really something that
changed the zeitgeist changed everything
okay number two 1973 the exorcist
i didn't see it in the theater i was
only four when this came out
but i did end up seeing it later on this
is another
classy ass [ __ ] horror movie up there
with like the omen i always thought the
exorcist and the omen were kind of
similar
um all right the exorcist is like
10 times better than them i don't know
but i love that i like the human too i
thought they're about the same the
exorcist had a lot of good dialogue in
it
like and uh what was his name max von
sydow [ __ ] knocks it out of the park
with this with the world in in this
movie everything about the exorcist
is really good okay look here's the next
one
number one all right this is jenny's
favorite jenny's favorite movie from the
70s
suspiria 1977. i'm sorry i just can't
i mean suspiria yeah i know it doesn't
make any sense
i saw it was a good-looking movie i was
amazing
yeah yeah i don't know there's
there's something about it that just
hits that sweet spot for me
yeah i can watch it over and over again
and like i said
it's like i can watch the exorcist over
and over again i can watch alien ever
again i can watch
burnt offerings i can watch don't look
down like all of the top 10 movies that
i have right there
if somebody said hey you want to watch
this [ __ ] right now and be like yeah
sure
so that's kind of how i wait what are
you doing with that
you don't need that anymore that's kind
of how i judged it
i was kind of like if somebody asked me
right now do i want to watch this movie
right now
like if you wanted to watch it again
right now would you watch it right now
so that's kind of how i tried to
because it was really hard for me to
like you know winnow everything down
um so that was hard but
that's kind of how i judged everything
okay so you know
okay so we're going like now we're in
the 1980s wait somebody said
i thought somebody said something that i
had to answer
but maybe it's gone now all right 1980s
now this
decade mrs mrs evans already party says
tom and jenny thank you my family's
stranded in a hotel
right now because of the midwestern
storms this is making me happy
well uh thank you miss evans man we're
gonna like we're gonna stand here we got
so much [ __ ] to talk about
speak english we got something she can
talk about right okay
1980s okay number 20. this was the
hardest decade
i'm just gonna say right now because i
had my original list
had 72 movies
so i had to take 52 movies off yeah
so if there was a movie that you love
from the 80s
that you're like hey why isn't that on
there it probably was on there
but i had to take it off yeah number 20
phantasm 2006 1988
all every movie in the phantasm uh i
love
all the things yeah and actually okay
look
the phantasm um property or ip
if that's what we want to call it was uh
was a labor of love created
by a single man and he stars in every
one of them
i think there's five of them five movies
phantasm is the only series that i've
ever seen that got better as it went
they were all good and it got better as
it went and which is good to show you
that
that if somebody really cares about the
property and the story
they will write a good story and execute
a good movie uh corporations can't do
that
multi-billion dollar corporations have a
really hard time
even with like part two or part three
well their whole thing
is they need to make money for as many
investors as possible
so they're not worried about one person
in their vision and whatever right so
that's kind of part of the problem yeah
okay number 19
hell raisers 1997.87
i liked it when it came out love climb
barking yeah
i really like tailracer when it came out
honestly hell raiser
the first one yeah um i think that was
the closest
approximation of clive barker's
vision to the screen it's
to be fair clive barker [ __ ] the [ __ ]
that he writes
is very difficult to
kind of um make it to a movie yeah
yeah i i s when it came out in 87 i
really enjoyed it
uh me and my [ __ ] buddies from high
school just would watch him man that was
some badass [ __ ]
i've watched it recently and found that
it was well made movie but boring
by today's standards i thought it was
kind of boring it did i don't think it
aged very well
but back in 87 it was really cool and i
understand why it's still a classic
i understand why it's on this list i
mean it was an important movie
yeah but to me it's boring now pat says
his possession
uh on this list it was but i had to take
it off
right unfortunately number eighteen
serpent
and the rainbow 1998 that was a great
[ __ ] haitian zombie like i said i
love
old school booty movies good i had about
a book
yeah yeah this is based on the book by
wade davis which is like a nonfiction
book and i think this was like a pretty
good approximation but they
added a bunch of like i said we did a um
you know
a review of that and
i don't know there's something about
this movie i really liked i really like
really like this movie 17
is the beyond yeah i don't know the
beyond
it's lucio folgi yeah we did a review of
it
a while back which so you watched it but
you probably don't remember
yeah um if i didn't grow up with the
italian movie i would have not really
retained it
you know what i'm talking about the
beyond i don't know this is like one of
my favorite
i love lucio fulchi's
i love his gore [ __ ] but i kind of love
his weird like
surrealism kind of [ __ ] yeah and the
beyond
is kind of like the it's kind of like
the [ __ ]
you know the whole [ __ ] thing of his
surrealism i don't even really
know if he realized that it was
surrealism
but to other people's aesthetic
it seems surrealistic okay but
i love the [ __ ] beyond so yeah so
that was my number seven number 16 is
the presenter
1987. predator was a great horror movie
it was very similar to jaws in a certain
way
when you think about it you're just
uncontrollable monster that [ __ ] eats
you
or kills you uh but it was a war movie
it was a it was a horror movie and a war
movie
i liked it it was one of the this was
this movie actually
influenced me back in high school to
want to go into the military ended up
joining the army
partially because this movie ridiculous
but that's just the way things were
well yeah when you're a kid you're like
oh yeah i like the predator but uh and
there when i and then when i got in the
506 there were two guys that actually
had that goddamn predator tattooed on
them
tattoos i have to say i mean the
predator
makeup yeah it was convincing for the
time
was fantastic when i was watching that
whole movie in the theater
when it was brand new with the audience
around me and i was watching it when i
lived in brazil
and it was subtitled in portuguese but
it was english language
and i was just listening to the reaction
of the [ __ ] brazilians that were in
there and they were losing
their [ __ ] minds and i'm watching and
i'm going
this is a great movie but it's not over
yet you know what i mean it's just
maybe it will disappoint me at the end
when that thing took its mask off
i was like whoa the whole crowd just was
oh because i can't see anything
and then when i saw that face for the
first time i said
this movie's a masterpiece this is gonna
go down in history and i was [ __ ]
right
i was right that movie went down in
[ __ ] history that was the first time
you saw the face of a
kind of a humanoid type alien and you
were totally convinced that you just
seen a goddamn extraterrestrial
i mean i mean the alien from alien 1
looked good
but you didn't see it that clearly this
thing you see it clearly and you go
and it was like you were coming face to
face with a [ __ ] extraterrestrial
and it was all starting to make sense
now you're like oh
that's yeah okay you know and then the
atomic bomb and the arm no no
and this is back when arnold was in his
prime and arnold hit about his prime you
know at 40
and it's just to this day this movie and
i'm gonna say that close second would be
[ __ ] terminator
terminator one not two people love two
nah terminator one two didn't age as
well i'm
i'm more into one one yeah one was more
simple
honestly and he was a villain the fact
that predator
yeah turned up at number 16 should tell
you
how [ __ ] awesome the 80s were for
horace because it
it was really like hard for me to like
rank [ __ ]
yeah and like i said you shouldn't like
[ __ ] take this as
whatever but because i had a hard time
like
sorting this [ __ ] out okay number 15
evil dead the first one the first one
now this i love the evil dead
because it was like a bunch of dudes
that just went out to a cabin in the
middle of nowhere we're just gonna like
we're gonna do some [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] claymation or whatever the [ __ ]
they did and
we're going to do all these camera
effects and it's like [ __ ] fantastic
spoiler alert evil dead 2 will be higher
up on the list because i feel like that
was
well that was the remake more of what
they wanted to do
and i i feel like all around that was
about a better movie
this one came out what 81 81 all right
it came out in 81
but what was funny is that they kept
replaying it over and over again
i think we saw this thing at the drive
in in michigan
at around like 80 86 maybe
they were still playing it at the
driving well they were and well like i
said the 80s was the hardest cars in the
back were bouncing
artists those cars in the back of the
[ __ ] thing would be bouncing you
know man there's [ __ ] tracy and
[ __ ] you knew the [ __ ] drive-in
was something i don't know some of you
youngsters don't know anything about it
it was a [ __ ] hotel
it was a hotel for teenagers [ __ ] was
[ __ ] [ __ ] your house
couldn't [ __ ] in the house you could
[ __ ] us and then you'd be like in the
front seat your boy
your boy you're being a front seat your
girlfriend your date and your boy be in
the backseat of his date
all kinds of wild [ __ ] be going on
you're [ __ ] like giving each other
high fives across the [ __ ] seats back
there
it was [ __ ] wild man it was like a
while
and and it happened because we didn't
have cell phones back then
you couldn't record anything so if it
happened nobody saw it then that [ __ ]
didn't happen nowadays somebody's trying
to [ __ ] record it
you know that's how that would just be
everywhere it'd be everywhere but back
in those days you
recorded it down it was [ __ ] wild
okay
next one number 14 the fly the fly 1986.
that was the time honestly i love david
cronenberg i love what is like
um underground [ __ ] but i have to say
his remake of the fly probably the best
synthesis of his vision
with mainstream
cinema it was a good movie that has ever
been because
he did a really good job in mixing body
horror
with um you know an emotional connection
with the characters um because i feel
like a lot of people
you know had heard of david cronenberg
but it's like oh it's like that's some
weird body horror [ __ ] they don't want
to watch that
but the fly was kind of like his first
foray
into mainstream cinema and i think he
like [ __ ] succeeded in that in
[ __ ] spades man
i mean honestly a lot of people would
say this was his best movie and i'm not
gonna argue with that like i don't agree
necessarily but that's subjective but
i mean as a synthesis of all the [ __ ]
i i really kind of maybe this is his
best movie
yeah it's a good movie okay number three
nightmare down the street it's
no it's not i'm waiting i'm not at three
no no
thirteen number thirteen nightmares 1984
84. this is another good one now when
this [ __ ] first came out it was like
breaking new ground i remember that
movie wes craven when he made this movie
i kind of feel like this was
the perfect synthesis of the slasher
movie
with a with a higher philosophical
weird kind of because he got the idea
from
i guess there were some like people that
had died in like
asia or whatever it was like from having
nightmares
and like they died during the nightmares
and he had read an article about it and
he's like look i'm gonna synthesize that
with the whole [ __ ] slasher thing
and i think the whole fact that he took
the slasher genre and like kind of
elevated it to another dimension
yeah and he made this like look that
there's this killer and he can kill you
in your dreams
so we can do kind of anything it was
very it was a very trendy
[ __ ] fantastic concept now everybody
liked it
i will say out of all the um
sequels i like the third one dream
warriors
was good um the kind of one that he did
that was like a meta one that was
kind of like it wasn't the final
nightmare it was
i don't remember what it was called but
the one where everybody's playing
themselves that one was good too
but for my money the original
nightmare on elm street was really
really scary well that was here that was
like the original that was like
that was the thing i mean i think that
was broken all the ground as they went
they actually
if you ask me they got worse i think the
second one might have been
pretty good maybe better okay
but like the third one was really good
okay um
but then it kind of like went into
stupid directions but then like they
went
meta and then that was good and then
after that they did a whole
freddy versus jason thing and it was
just which was fun
but you know okay number 12 evil dead 2.
this was a good one too but really which
essentially was an it's a
remake of evil of the first one but with
a higher budget better budget
and i think that evil dead too and
you know fight me but i think evil dead
too
i think they kind of like they
they kind of got what they wanted from
the first one but they didn't have the
budget
yeah and i think they kind of like kind
of
did it yeah it was good okay now um
number 11 reanimator 1985 this is a
great flick this is the first
movie i've i've seen uh uh but
like this there this this company made a
lot of them like the next one was
from beyond [ __ ] it had [ __ ] heard
it later it was it was a great it was a
great movie it was uh
way ahead of his time and it was very
illicit it's
there's a scene where
an undead on an undead dude with his
overhead gives a woman head while she's
on a [ __ ] yeah
and it was we were just [ __ ] tripping
it was like whoa
i mean in the 80s that was kind of nice
it was cutting edge
cutting edge like dude yeah like a woman
receiving
cunning lingus from a severed head
yeah all right i'm on board with that we
ought to have him on
that's what rihanna like if we could get
jeffrey combs
he comes huh oh my god jeffrey combs
goes on shows where they have ten
thousand subs
we can get him off oh hang out we have
one of the times yeah
he's cool he's very cool too he's having
a good time on our show
we have to stay sober though he'd
probably get although that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] drinking his ass off on this
one
yeah okay um number ten yeah
video drone the uh [ __ ] classic 1983
yeah again 19 david cronenberg man
yeah i mean well it's also had deborah
harry in it
and it was it was just a video jerome
was kind of creepy
creepy it was it was a concept that was
way ahead of its time it was about a
dude
who had videotaped all his conversations
and had them kept in a damn library
and he had a foundation that was going
around getting homeless people
to show them video and in the video was
a signal
that could [ __ ] hijack your brain and
get you to not know the difference
between reality and video images
and when you went to ask dude any
question i forgot what his name was
he talked to you in videotape and
[ __ ] a dude finds this signal who
works at a television station
and [ __ ] and the signals being
broadcast through a channel called video
drone
which is torture porn but it's real
torture like bdsm porn
and the signal's coming through and it's
making it's getting him addicted and
they're starting
they turn him into an assassin it's
[ __ ] bizarre um
i mean pretty ahead of it it's kind of
like a
he's kind of like a james bond type
figure for this [ __ ] cult
to try to take over the world and man
it's just [ __ ] weird hides the gun
inside his stomach [ __ ] pulls his
hand out of the stomach yeah
he's got a video on the end video
putting videotapes inside of his stuff
david cronenberg is very into technology
merged with organic you know
body anatomy so i mean
if you've seen existence if you've seen
any of his later movies
yeah he's very into like tiva says she's
going to watch it this weekend i think
she's talking about video girl
you should i mean everybody should see
videos yeah it's got to see that one
that one's just
it'll kind of disorient you it's very
creepy okay
number nine american well wolf in london
that's pretty good i like this one this
is like it's
weird because it's like a horror comedy
kind of i guess about some guys that
[ __ ] uh
american dudes that go to london and
[ __ ] get bit by a werewolf and he
comes back to the united states yeah one
of them does and [ __ ]
and he's weird and the
the nice thing about it i my favorite
thing about it is that
the character that gets bit by the wolf
and he dies and then he comes back as a
ghost
yeah and the more he comes back he's
like more and more
[ __ ] rotted like i thought red is
that the
kid that gets bit by a [ __ ] werewolf
and turns into where he's a jewish kid
so he's constantly having these
nightmares of these damn nazi werewolves
and they look [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
because they show him in the movie
[ __ ] werewolves and nazi outfits it's
with machine guns and [ __ ] that's pretty
[ __ ] cool
i mean easily the best werewolf man yeah
okay all right
so number eight the changeling this was
a [ __ ] great 1980.
george c scott i love
[Music]
haunted house movies i love goose movies
yeah
this is one of the best ones and this is
one of the best ones because
it doesn't show a lot yeah it's a very
slow burn but it's kind of spooky it was
way ahead of its time
it's taking place in this [ __ ]
awesome looking kind of house that's
supposed to be haunted
and you're watching this thing and you
go man that's a fantastic house
turns out you find out later if you ever
read anything about the movie that that
was a set but you
i was convinced it was a house i thought
it was too and when they showed him
outside
it wasn't a house it was just a facade
of a house
but they they will convince you that
that happened in the house but it's
george c
scott in a [ __ ] go in a [ __ ]
haunted house movie it's very good
he chooses chews up all the scenery
does this [ __ ] patent voice
you know it's just it's just [ __ ]
awesome and he's kind of doing uh
what call it he's kind of doing an
investigation he tries to find out why
he's being haunted that's [ __ ] really
what the movie's about
the cool thing about the changeling is
that
it's kind of like
they they do a lot with a little because
the thing about it it's like
um the uh setting is doing a lot of the
heavy lifting
but the thing about it is that if you
can take them
if you can make a take a movie
where a red ball coming down the stairs
is scary then
you have succeeded yeah in my
estimation because it's like it's hard
to do but like the way they set it up
is really really really creepy and the
fact that they cast
george c scott at it is significant
because
he was like this dude he played patton
he played all these like
big [ __ ] scary characters and the
fact that he was acting scared in the
[ __ ]
that made you want to be scared also
yeah okay now number seven is dead
ringers 1988 this was a great flick
david one of the prettiest movies you
can see
actually dead ringers the way it's
filmed the color palette and everything
it looked great
i love dead rings this is probably my
favorite yeah
david cronenberg movie i mean you know
it depends on the day but
i love um dead ringers just because
and we did a show a long time ago about
the brothers that this was based on
um the two gynecologists and they kind
of went nuts and
died it was based on
but really what was great about this
movie just the way it looked the way it
was shot for me
you know what i mean and jeremy irons
and the color palette was really good
playing the twins yeah was astounding
you really believed that those were two
different people
very classy looking high quality sure
for a horror movie
okay um the next one would be number six
aliens no number five
yeah aliens was good that was alien too
that pretty much goes without saying
everybody's seen this movie
i mean i like alien better but aliens is
also
one of the things that really not only
is this a fantastic story
one of the things that really stands out
to me is all the props there was no cgi
they actually did build [ __ ] armored
vehicles and
uh they built guns that actually shot
out of tops of submachine guns inside of
kits
made up uniforms for the marines they
made the whole [ __ ]
hadley's hope [ __ ] compound and got
away it was just a very it
it really made you feel like you were
there you know
and then of course there's aliens and
there's a lot of them and they're
shooting them up
uh thing is is that it is a some people
would call it a horror movie it was also
very much like an action movie too
so yeah i kind of like i debated whether
i was gonna because some of the movies
that i put on here i was kind of like is
this
really a horror movie and i'm like i
didn't really do it but i mean
aliens it's sci-fi horror
yes so yeah tila you'd like uh dead
ringers it's good it's about two
it's about the it's psychological twins
that are gynecologists
that are [ __ ] losing their goddamn
minds it's pretty good
i mean if you like david cronenberg you
would like it number three
i'm not sure no number five number five
excuse me it's called the hunger the
hunger
in 1983. yeah this is my easily my
favorite
vampire baby of all time had bauhaus in
the opening
david bowie isn't it he's in it
catherine de nova is in it bauhaus are
in it
yeah if you're a goth this is your
quintessential this is the
quintessential
goth it's one of the first gothic goth
movies i think
it might have been i mean i can't really
think uh honestly
when i was a kid i watched this movie
over and over and over again yeah
because vampires basically
susan you get to see
katherine denove and susan sarandon like
make out
yeah and david bowie in there david
bowie's in there oh my god it's so good
like bass does music it's so so good
okay number four
fright night 1985 this is a classic
that's a good feel-good horror movie
love you guys before friday from 1985.
this is a
uh horror comedy and it's basically
about like
ronnie mcdowell's in it and he's
fantastic and it's like this [ __ ]
movie about this vampire moves into this
house next door to this teenager
and he notices that there's a vampire
and he's trying to like talk everybody
into hey there's a vampire next door
that's killing people and nobody
believes him
and it's so it's sort of like a horror
comedy it's so
so good me always thought this was kind
of a lighter-hearted version
so well done i thought this was a hot
lighter-hearted version
of say like salem's lot it had a very
80s [ __ ]
kind of like gremlinsy kind of a feel to
it it's like yeah
it's it's a feel good fun it's like
something that spielberg would have made
sure it's a great movie okay number
three creep show 1982
yeah you guys know i love horror
anthologies
creep show easily the best horror
anthology
ever made really good okay number two
1982 the thing
the thing this is some [ __ ] classic
my dad took me to see it three times
back when it came out and then
and this this movie here [ __ ] changed
my life because i was [ __ ] scared
about that there could be an alien that
could [ __ ] come
first i saw the blob about an alien
coming down on it down
wait the original of the remake did the
original saw the original for when an
alien came down inside a meteorite and
that worried me
then i saw this other alien come down
that absorbs you could turn you into
anything
blew my [ __ ] mind that was the
beginning of me [ __ ] knowing who kurt
russell was
that was the beginning of the crusal
sphere and keith david
keith davis keith david [ __ ]
impressed the [ __ ] out of me out of that
movie
they did keep david krussel dynamic
i should say if you haven't like i had
to leave it off the list but if you
haven't seen
the remake of the blob from the 1980s
you should probably see it because the
remake of the blob
was pretty fantastic yeah and it's like
super gory
okay number one number one dude you know
what this is we know what number one's
gonna be
[ __ ] number one is the shining 1980
that's for the 80s
this is the movie from the show
from the 80s that i never get tired like
[ __ ] if you said to me today like right
now
do you want to watch the shining sure
yeah you can watch that anytime anyplace
where's the uh oh no did it crash please
tell me it's in the crash
i tried to move the dam i think it
crashed again
that's something i think it crashed
again
there we go there we go no no no no
don't get too excited
trying to move don't get excited because
she's telling me don't get excited don't
get excited because how the hell could
that how could the hell could moving the
mouse crash the goddamn thing
it's not it doesn't have anything to do
with the mouse it's just
going to crash oh no oh no
we only got to the 90s
i know it's gone oh come on
no no please don't please don't please
don't please don't
please don't please don't
just let it go okay then here's
okay now let's see see if it scrolls up
there you go what stop
all right all right all right there you
go hopefully
all right we're at the 19 we're at the
1990s no we we were talking about like
1980s like i said my number one the
shining
easy i mean it was hard because like the
shining of the thing i love
both of those equally but if somebody
said to me
hey you wanna watch the shining today
paul said that we used up all the ram
moving the cursor yeah
yeah if somebody said to me hey you
wanna shining i i will watch the shining
any day you want to like [ __ ] you
come to me like any random day hey you
wanna
shine sure i'll sit down and watch it
okay we gotta keep moving though we're
running out of time
we're not running out of time yes we are
jenny we have look we have
at least 20 uh 30 more years of these
things to do
i know that did it crash it's funny
probably did you probably crash
it says stop clicking
he's [ __ ] with it well he's like
touching stuff well
i have to scroll up for the list i think
it damn
probably i think it [ __ ] crashed
maybe not oh you know you're back back
is it back okay
i don't think i know i have to scroll
the list up
okay in order to see what the list is
but we have 30 more years of these we
can't talk
much about each one a couple lines if
not we're going to be here for another
three hours and the audience isn't going
to be able to hang with us
no i'm just trying to keep i'm just
trying to keep
keep us in touch with what's going on
ken says life force and the hunger got
me my first
freeway okay 1990s number 20 got chronos
and
this was much easier all right so number
20 chronos 1993
this was a very early uh guillermo del
toro
movie um about a vampire but also they
have like the weird thing of like a
[ __ ]
uh clockwork bug
type of thing that like made you into a
vampire so if you haven't seen chronos
you should probably check that out it's
very very if you like gamma del toro
like
ken fetter says defrag the computer
after the show
he said it might do it yeah okay number
number nine nineteen
castle free 1995. um
sort of based on an hp lovecraft story
the outsider
jeffrey combs is in it barbara crampton
is in it
and it's good we've done like a room
it's pretty good it's not one of my
favorite
um yeah it's movie but it's pretty good
but that's why it's like number 19
like i'm i'm into it but not bad this is
another good one not uh 18
body bags nice body bags 19.
john carpenter did this [ __ ] and um
i don't know like i i don't know i have
a lot of affection for body bags
mark hamill's in there it's like you
know there's the [ __ ] story about
like david warner is in it it's like the
[ __ ] dude was like the dude that was
growing all the hair it's just
it's just fun i don't know like i like
this one uh
[ __ ] pat hiffle goes we can hear you
your image doesn't have to move
pat you're dealing with jenny and you're
dealing with a drunk jenny when she sees
that [ __ ] freezing
she's going to go oh that's what it is
i get angry because she is not working
the way
i am expecting ken sent us some [ __ ]
flash bulbs and it still hasn't appeared
right there
i don't know that might have frozen oh
my god it didn't really
yeah i think the chat has frozen uh
this is really annoying yeah this is
annoying me
okay um well we're gonna keep talking
yeah because i don't i don't know
i think they could hear us all right so
18 we were a bodybuilder okay now number
17 bride of rihanna
brian every animator 19 90.
yeah um not as good as reanimator
obviously because nothing is
i liked it but it's not pretty good yeah
it's still pretty good
um you know what are you gonna do it
yeah you know it's
it's a worthy follow-up yeah okay now
number 16
interview with the vampire nice that was
the classic 94
classy classy vampire movie it's pretty
the only thing that i've
probably the only thing that i've liked
tom cruise in yeah
all right number 15 the frighteners
that's 1996 that's your favorite i like
this movie it was one of my favorites
this was kind of like the uh the back to
the future of horror movies
is where michael j fox plays a
paranormal investigator but he actually
he he can actually communicate with
ghosts
and he has a bunch of ghost friends and
they run around and [ __ ]
haunt houses and then he charges them
charges the
inhabitants money so he can exercise or
pretend to exercise
his friendly ghosts uh well while
they're out there they find a very
unfriendly ghost that they have to deal
with
and then um i think his name is i forgot
what his name was
uh michael j fox's character he kind of
has a dark past he's kind of like a
marty mcfly gone wrong but it's a very
good movie
didn't get any play back in 96 but uh
if you watch the full version there's a
director's cut it's much better than the
theatrical
cut you can see it on blu-ray it's a
hidden gem it's not one of those movies
it's like hard to classify
it's kind of like it's like a comedy but
a horror movie and it's kind of like i
don't know it's like it
it's in that weird like gray area yeah
number 14 in the mouth of madness yeah
that's a good physical
1994. that's kind of a [ __ ]
lovecraftian
movie that wasn't carpenter was it who
did that
um you know what
i don't know maybe it was it might have
been it might have been carpenter i
don't know i mean yeah is love crafty
and but not
based on a lovecraft story per se yeah
so it kind of has that vibe to it
but not essentially well like we did a
um we did a review on that as well
number 13 bram stoker's dracula yeah the
1992 one it's good
which we've done a review on that as
well other than
keanu reeves and winning riders
yeah questionable british accents
yeah um actually badger said that that
was carpenter for in the mouth
i thought it was i thought it was too
brown because dracula was a [ __ ]
it's a it's a classic for now i will say
that it is
of the adaptations of dracula of which
there have been hundreds
probably one of the most um
the closest adaptations to the novel
still not exactly the same but
close still pretty good though um but i
wish they would have used more british
actors
like i said number 12. scream 1996.
um this movie i like this movie
and i understand how important it was
because scream from 1996
kind of kicked off the whole
ironic um meta horror boom
of the late 90s and early 2000s which
i'm not a fan of
i have to say but i did think that
scream
directed by wes craven was
very well done because it was kind of
like the first one to do that [ __ ]
and so i'm not going to blame him thank
you ken
yeah that was funny because that was
from a long time ago so the chat it was
starting now
yeah so i kind of feel like i i don't
want to [ __ ]
like i like scream as a movie but
i kind of feel like i don't like it
because
it encouraged all of the [ __ ] that came
later
like in the late 90s and early 2000s
like hey we're going to make all these
like meta
horror movies where it's like
self-referential and it's like all this
and i didn't really like that yeah um
so i'll blame it for that but
he was kind of the first one to do it
and he was like but so i'm not gonna
like blame for that he didn't know
okay number 11 the access history don't
touch that what
don't touch that no you'll freeze the
screen i won't
you'll freeze the screen i have to
scroll down because i have yeah i do
you can see all of them didn't want to
one just let it go it doesn't have
anything to do with me scrolling
seriously um
so number eleven yeah exorcistic
three nineteen ninety which we have also
that we've all said
this is a really good movie and it's
also really a great standalone you don't
have to see the
other exorcist it really doesn't have
anything jersey scott in this
really good acting uh [ __ ] script is
fantastic
fantastic real good um uh jump scare in
it a couple times
just good story really good and like i
said you don't even need to see exorcist
one or two
i think exorcist two is a bomb for what
i remember i think that's exorcist two
was kind of terrible yeah okay number
ten the blair witch project that's 1399.
i will give it okay so there had been
found footage movies before this um
hello cannibal holocaust
but blair witch hollow uh blair witch
project
was kind of like the first one to do it
for a mainstream thing and i will give
blair witch project the props
for getting on to um early internet [ __ ]
like making a whole website and like
pretending the [ __ ] was real like almost
like an
alternate reality uh game type of [ __ ]
so i will
give them credit for doing that [ __ ] and
also i saw blair witch project in the
theater and honestly i knew it was fake
but they did a really good job of
giving you that verisimilitude they
really made you feel like
it was a real thing that was happening
and it was a real
urban legend and if you bought into it
that it was
super scary i thought yeah attila that
brad dora
scene was [ __ ] awesome from from
exorcist three that was a really good
movie
yeah yeah did we freeze again it's
freezing but there's they can still hear
us
okay um number nine raven
avenues 1990. now if you guys
or 1999 rather yeah if you guys
are crying for movies about
wendigos um
please see ravenous
why is this popping up i don't know who
this happened okay i don't know why that
happened
that's something just popped up in front
of everything
okay hold on hold on oh my god
can i pee or are you just gonna exactly
i'm just trying to fix it for you
you're not gonna fix anything okay go
ahead you don't really
know what's going on i don't really know
what's going on
go ahead trying to figure out what the
hell is going on here okay it's back
it's back all right she went to the
restroom
and uh yeah we're having problems the uh
computer's [ __ ] freezing up
computer's freezing up i'm trying to
move the show as quickly as i can
because we still have a lot to do
and jenny's had to had a bit to drink so
we're gonna see looks like it's frozen
can you guys still hear me
okay you guys can still hear me
yeah i'm having serious trouble on this
end
it's just like uh that's freezing and
that's freezing
so we're having computer problems we may
have to restart the stream
can you guys still hear me
it's getting really really glitchy it's
back now
but i'm not sure if it'll make it it's i
think it's on
our people they say they said yeah the
videos work and they can hear us
jesus christ all right like where the
[ __ ] are we
uh we were actually all right x-rays
okay so we talked about holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude what did you do
i didn't do anything okay
all kind of weird [ __ ] i didn't touch
anything okay
so like i said blair witch project good
found footage movie
like i said i'm not a big fan of found
footage but that was a good one
um number nine ravenous yeah
if you guys have not seen ravenous i saw
this
i saw this in the theater back in 1999
i don't think people realized
that it was supposed to be yeah she does
have a lot of windows open
a black comedy um
so it's about it's set during the
um what do you call it the [ __ ]
war of 1812 i think and
i i don't think people got that it was
like one it's based on the wendigo
legend
like hey like somebody that eats people
because they had to
like they turned into a monster which
was like a native american legend
and so they took that and then they like
ran with it
and i don't think people realized that
it was supposed to be like
funny i don't know like i saw in the
theater and i thought it was hilarious
but like a lot of people that i was in
the theater with
did not really seem to think it was
hilarious so i thought i was like a
weirdo
yeah i thought it was very funny but i
don't know maybe i have like a weird
sense of humor okay number eight army of
darkness that's nineteen ninety two
let's see braveness if you haven't seen
it yet
uh army of darkness 1982 obviously the
third movie
in the evil dead trilogy my probably my
least favorite
um because i just i didn't like the like
the medieval setting as much
but still [ __ ] awesome still [ __ ]
funny
i mean bruce campbell he can do no wrong
as far as i'm concerned he's [ __ ]
hilarious he's awesome
okay number seven jacob's ladder that's
1990 yeah yeah all right
that was that i i didn't really like
that one i thought that was kind of
boring but
yeah okay and then no man that's a good
one
all right number six the craft in 1996.
you missed one number five misery nobody
didn't
number six the craft number six
oh okay we also did a
uh review yeah okay all right number
five misery 1990
that was that uh that was a stephen king
adaptation
yep uh novel's good too yeah the novel
is really good too
we froze up no we're still there are we
it looks like it okay um great
yeah i mean this computer needs to be
reset all right
yeah well we've been streaming for hours
and it and it he could be right that we
need to re to defrag this computer
okay um the next one would be number
four
uh wait we did that we did misery misery
okay
number stir of echoes yeah 1999. now
this was based on we did a review of it
this is based on a novel or novel a
novella by richard matheson this came
out
pretty much exactly the same time as
what was that [ __ ] uh m night
shyamalan ding dong
[ __ ] movie i don't know the sixth
sense
yeah so it came out pretty much i think
it came out the same day
so everyone was kind of like well we
want to see the ghost movie
we'll see this big ghost movie that came
out which is i gotta bring
in and so nobody saw star of echoes
which to me and we did a review of it
and i was kind of like bummed out about
it because i'm like look
this star of echoes was
i'm gonna say objectively a better movie
than the sixth sense the sixth sense was
a good movie too
but i kind of feel like the thing about
the sixth sense is that
once you already know the twist
because that's kind of his thing
i don't know if it says enjoyable star
of echoes
to me is creepier just even if you
already know how it's going to go
um and like i said this is based on our
richard matheson novel
so which is also creepy i don't know
like i was just
more scared by stir echoes the movie
than i was by
the sixth sense your mileage may vary
but i'm just saying they came out at the
same time
and i was kind of bummed that they
didn't that it didn't get as much
attention so i always kind of try to
plug it to people
so that's why it's like so far up in my
list also because i
really like that movie a lot so starbeck
is 19.99
number three i'm going to go with
cemetery man
1994 also known as de la morte de la
moray
um we reviewed this not too long ago did
you find her couldn't find her
well you didn't look that hard didn't
you i can't i can't we
we have to finish up the show all right
so where are you at now
number three okay cemetery this is what
we're gonna do we're gonna end it here
and then we'll
next week we'll continue with the rest
of the stuff because we won't be able to
make it that's another couple hours
all right all right so um guys we're
gonna
we're gonna finish up with the 90s and
then next week we're going to do
the 2000 2010 and 2020.
all right so we're going to end it here
in a in uh in a few more minutes okay
yeah we can't really we gotta
go find what should we do and the
computer's giving us problems
keeps like crashing i don't even know if
you guys are like seeing the [ __ ]
yeah they've seen it okay and most of
them are still here
hopefully yeah like i said number three
cemetery man we've done like a thing
about that
yeah um number two i'm going to give you
silence of lambs 1991 which one
like [ __ ] all the oscars that year um
i've read the book as well it's like
it's just a really good story
it's like it's something i've seen a
million times it's just like all the
acting in it
fantastic it's like just a really really
good movie
number one this is the number one for
the 1990s candyman
candyman 1992. this is one of jenny's
favorite 90s movies it's
this is my favorite 90s i mean it's a
competition but it's a well-crafted
flick it came out of [ __ ] left
field back in the 90s like we were
hearing about it and then we went
we went and rented it and we were like
man that was some [ __ ]
that was some wild [ __ ] it was its own
thing
well that's why i like it it went in its
own direction
yeah and i like kind of like a higher
class version of freddie
yeah i like that they went and and i
like to
that they kind of set it in kind of a
quote-unquote ghetto sort of area it was
like it was something that you didn't
see a lot
thanks badger appreciate it thank you
just send us ten pounds
oh thank you it was something that you
didn't really see a lot particularly in
the 90s
and so i feel like maybe i don't know
like
maybe i had seen some [ __ ] before that
but like this was one of the first
big movies that i had seen that was set
in that
um environment and it was kind of like
i don't know it was just kind of like a
new take on it i like the like the whole
urban legend aspect i
liked the whole [ __ ] and [ __ ] tony
todd and it was
amazing so dude's got a fantastic voice
yeah and so as i said if they remake it
um i'm not averse to them remaking it
but i kind of feel like tonytown has to
be
in there somewhere yeah okay so that's
the
end of the list for today i mean i still
got two thousand
and two thousand times on the [ __ ] on
next wednesday
which that uh which you guys will you
know we'll have fun then
is there uh is there anything you guys
want to say before we uh
check off you can [ __ ] tell us in the
comment section we didn't even get to
the elisa lamb stuff or the nostradamus
stuff
i'm telling you jenny talk about the
nostradamus we got no
well we could we don't have time jenny
we gotta it's getting late
and we've been on for a long time and we
can do all this stuff nick
jenny has a tendency to like prepare
notes for the show that are like
six times larger than you actually need
it's because i don't even for a
four-hour show because
sometimes it only takes a little when i
talk about stuff
like i'll talk about stuff and he'll
just look at me like yeah
and i won't have then i'll be like okay
so i have to like talk about other stuff
so i don't really know if he's gonna
like go off on the stuff
yeah or if he's not going to go off and
stuff so i don't really know so i have
to kind of like
have to be prepared they're they're
talking about mama waldy and blackyland
[ __ ] like that
yeah [ __ ] i wish they would bring
blacula back
i don't think they could bring it back
i just kind of feel like nobody but that
dude could play that
role yes true all right guys um
it's uh we didn't even talk about the
elisa lamb show we didn't yeah
we'll have to talk about it next time
okay well it's it's uh thanks for
joining us tonight
if you like the show please like share
and subscribe
um [ __ ] if you uh you can drop us a
line on facebook
and uh we're on instagram too is there
anything else you need to say jenny
well i don't think so okay well we'll
see you guys uh when
when are we streaming next um well
saturday we're doing the main show
yeah okay which is about the source
family okay so there's nothing right
yeah
okay so we'll see you guys saturday and
then sunday we're doing a matinee show
okay oh [ __ ] like it froze up again oh
my god we'll see you guys
seriously don't push that don't push
that all right i'm sorry guys
just trying to wait
what i don't know like it no it
disappeared
it disappeared the computer is glitching
out like a [ __ ] and we've been
on that we've been on why
why look i gotta find the cat okay
i gotta find the cat why
all right so we i don't know i had a lot
of [ __ ] i want to talk about but
whatever we'll talk about it like some
other time
um i don't know my [ __ ] froze
whatever hopefully you guys are still
seeing me and hearing me um we will be
back
on saturday we're going to talk about
the source family
cult and we're going to be talking about
maybe some other goals too i don't
really know we'll
find out when we get there um but thanks
for tuning in and i'm
seriously we only got up to the 90s i
have a list for the 2000s and the 2010s
up until now
so we'll get into that later
but thanks everybody for dropping by
sorry about like all the [ __ ]
drop-offs [ __ ] happens
um we will see you guys on saturday
hopefully oh [ __ ] it froze again um
we'll see you guys on saturday hopefully
and
that'll do it for today's show
please come back on saturday
and we'll see you then